[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle saison sur
public sénat et on commence par un
moment fort au sénat les premières
questions d'actualité au gouvernement de
cette session parlementaire et on va
vous faire vivre cet après midi avec
toute notre équipe fidèle au poste c'est
d'abord notre commentateur dans la
tribune de presse de l'hémicycle du
sénat quentin calmet bonjour quel est le
programme de ses premières questions
d'actualité sérieux nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle saison on attend des
thèmes forts sur le pouvoir d'achat ou
la cause des prix des matières premières
avec des prises de parole de jean castex
sur ces sujets on voit aussi revenir
avec trois questions sur la situation
sanitaire dans les outre mer et enfin
qu'on attend une question venue dlr sur
un sujet très sensible les retraites
alex lui avec cette question la réforme
des retraites est elle vraiment enterrés
pour ce quinquennat nous sont également
avec notre interviewé heures en salle
des conférences du sénat pour recueillir
les réactions des sénateurs et des
ministres steve jourdain qui aurait vous
à votre micro bonjour alex bonjour à
tous on sera dans quelques instants avec
la sénatrice communiste laurence cohen
on parlera avec elle la rentrée sociale
dans un instant et enfin nous serons
avec le streamer politique jean masia
qui va à commenter cette séance de
questions d'actualité sur la plateforme
twitch avec toute sa communauté dans
l'émission sénat stream salut jean
comment ça va et quelles sont les
préoccupations de la communauté pour
cette rentrée du parlement salut
alexandre effectivement tu l'as dit
rentrée assez chaude h est chargé en
tout cas on l'a appris ce matin la
convocation en vue d'une possible mise
en examen d'agnès buzyn l'ancien
ministre de la justice par les
magistrats instructeurs
la cour de justice de la république pour
sa gestion un peu catastrophique faut le
reconnaître d'ailleurs ça avait été dit
par une commission d'enquêté sénatoriale
du que vide au début de la pandémie
c'est quelque chose qui interpelle
beaucoup les internautes et l'opinion
publique on a hâte de voir si des
sénateurs se saisisse de cette question
on a aussi évidemment le vote et la
prorogation de l'état d'urgence ce matin
par le sénat en outre-mer suite à suite
à l'explosion du taux d'incidence est
élevé et la propagation de la de la duc
au vide là bas ça aussi ça nous
intéresse on a hâte de voir ce qu'en dit
le gouvernement et comment est-ce que
les comment est-ce que la situation est
gérée à tout prix dire vouloir excuser
pour ma caméra et puis en train la
situation en afghanistan qui intéresse
beaucoup les internautes évidemment avec
la nomination du nouveau gouvernement
taliban eh bien merci beaucoup de gens
donc à 14h30 les sénateurs vont
interroger les ministres sur tous ces
sujets du moment mais d'abord c'est
l'heure du débat
[Musique]
et comme c'est la rentrée du parlement
et bien on va s'intéresser aux dernières
réformes de ce quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron qui ont été dessinés par le
premier ministre jean castex avec une
question qui se pose peut-on encore
réformé en sortie de crise sanitaire et
à la proche de l'élection présidentielle
on va faire le point d'abord sur
l'agenda du sénat avec jérôme rabiet
pour sa dernière année de mandature
l'exécutif ne compte pas freiner le
rythme de travail au parlement à la
sortie du séminaire de rentrée du
gouvernement jean castex promet d'agir
jusqu'à la présidentielle deux cents
jours pour agir jusqu'au bout car c'est
non seulement l'intérêt du pays mais
c'est évidemment la conception que nous
nous faisons
de notre responsabilité mais problème il
va y avoir embouteillage car les
sénateurs comme les députés arrêteront
le travail en séance le 26 février 2022
pour laisser place à la campagne
présidentielle et certaines semaines
sont déjà réservé de longue date c'est
le cas du marathon budgétaire
traditionnel de fin d'année le budget de
la sécurité sociale occupera les
sénateurs du 8 au 13 novembre puis le
projet de loi de finances sera débattu
en séance du 18 novembre au 7 décembre
en guise de reprise fin septembre les
sénateurs discuteront du projet de loi
pour la con dans l'institution
judiciaire dans les grands textes encore
attendues le gouvernement a confirmé son
souhait de mettre en oeuvre un revenu
d'engagement pour les jeunes qui ne sera
pas un rsa jeunes un projet de loi
relatifs à la responsabilité pénale et à
la sécurité intérieure sera aussi
discutée ce calendrier déjà chargé
pourrait évoluer si la crise sanitaire
s'en mêle cela avait été le cas lors du
premier confinement qui avait stoppé net
la réforme des retraites un dossier que
le premier ministre jean castex ne
souhaitent pas ouvrir dans les
conditions sanitaires actuelles vantant
le besoin d'apaisement du pays
et pour débattre des réformes de la fin
du quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
j'accueille sur ce plateau laurence
rossignol vous êtes sénatrice socialiste
de l'oise bonjour bonjour également jean
françois husson vous êtes sénateur
républicain de meurthe et moselle et
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances vous allez donc travaillé sur
le dernier budget dernier projet de loi
de finances de ce quinquennat
j'accueille également benjamin morel jeu
bonjour vous êtes docteur en sciences
politiques à le nsrs paris saclay et
maître de conférence en droit public à
paris 2 et puis j'accueille xavier
iacovelli sénateurs du groupe r des pays
la république en marche des
hauts-de-seine alors une question qui se
pose avec ce programme de cette session
parlementaire cette fin de quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron ses petons encore
réformé en sortie crise sanitaire à la
proche de la présidentielle jean
françois husson est ce que vous avez
l'impression que le gouvernement
continue à travailler à mener ses
réformes
si on ne regarde et si on écoute un peu
ce qui se dit on sent que c'est une
rentrée un peu avec beaucoup de
cafouillage on nous on a une petite
bombe qui part sur
ballon d'essai sur la réforme des
retraites
le premier ministre dit pas de réforme
des retraites et puis comme ça un
certain nombre de domaines dans lesquels
alors on a dit on a des mesures
je pense qu'il faut faire attention
on est encore dans un état de crise
sanitaire je pense que la france a
besoin aujourd'hui des plus tôt soudé et
rassembler et je ne vois pas moi
aujourd'hui fil conducteur est une des
difficultés pour pouvoir réformer il
fois il faut avoir je dirais un bloc de
confiance et cette confiance aujourd'hui
elle est largement érodé et entamer dans
l'opinion vous avez la comédie est ce
que le gouvernement a perdu son cap en
cette fin de quinquennat non on n'a pas
perdu son cap le président de la
république l'a dit nous l'a répété même
le 12 juillet à l'elysée auprès des
parlementaires de la majorité il
souhaite que nous puissions réformer la
france jusqu'au dernier moment jusqu'au
dernier quart d'heure et donc jusqu'au
26 février le gouvernement et la
majorité présidentielle seront à pied
d'oeuvre pour mettre en place les
réformes promises en 2017 et donc
effectivement il ya eu du retard de
parler 18 mois parce que deux ans de
crise sanitaire malgré tout le pays a
continué à être réformé on voit même que
d'un point de vue économique ce qui
avait été fait par anticipation de la
crise enfin en avant la crise pardon on
en voit maintenant les effets lecointe
il en coûte a permis de sauver notre
économie de sauver aussi les emplois en
france même l'insee vient de réévaluer à
la hausse à 6h26 pour cent le taux de
croissance pour pour pour cette année
donc on voit qu'il ya quand même un
certain nombre d'éléments positifs le
plan de relance de 100 milliards qui
avait été annoncé par le président de la
république on avait comme objectif d'en
faire 50 milliards d'ici la fin d'année
là nous sommes à 70 milliards qui seront
mobilisés fin décembre ça veut dire que
nos entreprises et l'économie se porte
bien et a confiance dans dans les mois
et dans les années à venir donc mans il
faut réformer jusqu'au bout et c'est
vraiment la volonté du président et et
du gouvernement à laurence rossignol
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce
programme parlementaire en cette fin de
quinquennat est ce qu'il va redonner
confiance aux français
je ne sais pas si avec le président de
la république est en campagne ça y est
pour lui la présidentielle est lancée il
l'a lancé sa campagne d'un certain point
de vue à marseille il ya quelques jours
j'entends bien et je comprends que le
gouvernement dise qu'il veut continuer à
réformer d'autant que point président
qui avait été élu sur le projet de la
réforme en fait quand on fait le bilan
des réformes alors probablement que le
coc vit dehors à bon dos mais le bilan
des réformes annoncées pas même macron
est quand même assez faible la grande
réforme de l'état par exemple qui
avaient été promises par présente dans
le public d'un état moins d'un état
moins bureaucratique d'un état plus
souple plus agile je vois aucune
différence aujourd'hui entre l'état tels
qu'ils étaient hier est tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui donc ça c'est une réforme
qui n'a pas eu lieu je veux pas dire
qu'elle a échoué parce que je crois
qu'elle n'a même pas été initiés au
comptant la haute administration est
encore plus puissante et la technocratie
encore plus active qu'elle ne l'était
auparavant la réforme des institutions à
n'a pas eu lieu on a toujours la cour de
justice de la république alors qu'on
avait quand même un certain nombre y
compris en faisant un public à vouloir
sa suppression donc le bilan des
réformes menées macron si je mets de
côté la suppression de l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune qui a été fait
un début de quinquennat et puis un
centre de mesures fiscales très
favorable aux très hauts revenus et puis
la réforme de l'éducation
il a réforme de l'assurance chômage qui
frappe beaucoup de personnes en
difficulté le bilan est pas terrible
donc ce que je comprends que le présent
veut le faire croire qu'il va pogner de
réformer en réalité la session
parlementaire elle est faite il ya le
budget le plfss la sécurité sociale et
puis aussi des textes en navette qui
font très bien voir arriver parce que
gouverner c'est pas simplement annoncer
ou faire voter des lois en première
lecture à l'assemblée est faux que la
navette continue j'attends en
particulier le texte la protection de
l'enfance qui est inscrit et qui doit
finir son chemin le texte sur les les
femmes dans les pointant les comités
exécutifs des grandes entreprises la loi
sur le bien-être animal dont il ya tout
un tas de navettes a terminé donc je
crois que le président a besoin de dire
qui va compter de réformer ce que
probablement ont fait d'autres avant lui
ce rayon
est jusqu'au dernier moment parce qu'il
a un déficit de réformes et parce qu'il
est en campagne oui un programme chargé
avec un risque benjamin morel
d'embouteillage parlementaire un quart
est bien là j'en ai eu le parlement se
termine fin février on l'a vu dans le
sujet de jérôme rabier et finalement est
ce qu'il ya des marges de manoeuvre pour
le gouvernement pour passer des réformes
y en a très peu et où vous enlever
certains textes à l'ordre et certains
textes et kate dès aujourd'hui sont un
peu un suspens on sait pas exactement et
ce qu'ils arriveront au bout parce qu'en
réalité
la décentralisation la voilà ça dépendra
en suisse et gouvernement veut mettre un
autre texte ya beaucoup de choses
aujourd'hui qui sont en effet
hypothéquer entre parenthèses et
également des textes en navette mais en
réalité c'est très très classique si
vous écoutez par exemple nicolas sarkozy
juste avant la campagne de 2012 il
prévoit une grande réforme du droit des
étrangers et du contentieux
administratif relatif aux étrangers je
crois au mois de janvier 2012 parce que
justement il faut faire des effets
d'annoncé et au moment vous avez le plus
besoin de faire des annonces d'aidé
effet d'annonce légistatives vous n'avez
plus le temps parlementaire parce que en
effet à partir du mois de février rideau
il n'y a plus rien qui passaient
qu'avant vous avez un budget donc là on
est dans quelque chose de très classique
crise sanitaire ou pas crise sanitaire
mais c'est malgré tout un avantage pour
un an président la république parce que
du coup les projets que vous lancer eh
bien vous les envoyer vers votre second
quinquennat et vous expliquer à
l'opinion que le projet de loi sur les
retraites il est fils tu es et que si
vous êtes réélu vous le ferez passer du
point de vue de la communication
politique ça peut être utile même si les
prédécesseurs d'emmanuel macron n'ont
jamais vraiment tirer profit alors en
tout cas il ya quand même deux grands
tests de grands textes pardon qui
peuvent être décisifs il s'agit du
budget projet de loi de finances et du
budget de la sécurité sociale
jean françois husson vous allez
travailler précisément sur ce dernier
budget du quinquennat le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire a dit que
c'était la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte
est ce que vous êtes aussi sur cette
ligne est ce que maintenant il faut
redresser un peu les dépenses publiques
mais la question c'est de savoir si on
est sur la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte
faut d'abord évaluer le quoi qu'il en
coûte pour garder sa pertinence son
efficacité aujourd'hui on a besoin
d'avoir une économie en bonne santé on a
besoin de redresser la situation et
d'améliorer encore la situation de
l'emploi on est dans une situation
paradoxale aujourd'hui on parle de
revenus d'engagement on a un système il
suffit d'écouter ce que disent les
français les chefs d'entreprise à cet
homme d'acteurs de salariés il trouve
pas trace aïe et en même temps on a un
système de protection sociale qui est
aujourd'hui de très bon niveau
donc il faut y apprennent dans
l'équation c'est la formation qu'elle
comment on réforme je dirais notre
système de formation depuis la formation
initiale en passant par la formation
professionnelle la formation tout au
long de la vie là il ya des vrais sujets
et aujourd'hui quand vous regardez le ça
va être un des sujets de la campagne
comment on remet la valeur travail et
comment on favorise plus et mieux que la
situation du jeu il a su assurer
aujourd'hui elle est dramatique pour nos
finances publiques il faut donc
effectivement parce que on est rentré
dans la crise en ayant par exemple par
rapport à l'allemagne on est déjà rentré
avec du retard avec des indicateurs
économiques et sociaux j'aurai
l'occasion d'en parler prochainement qui
sont préoccupants on sort de la crise on
est encore moins bien né quasiment les
derniers de l'union européenne sur un
certain nombre de grands indicateurs
économiques sociaux il faut en tenir
compte et donc il faut avoir la volonté
de redresser la situation d'autres pays
que nous l'ont fait c'est un devoir on a
une exigence de vérité on a hâte de voir
des résultats et en même temps il faut
rassembler les français faut recoudre il
faut réparer les fractures donc il faut
donner un élan oui double défi qui est
peut-être compliqué à mettre en oeuvre
xavier iacovelli est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cet impératif de
redressement économique economic de fin
du quoi qu'il en coûte qui a d'ailleurs
été est bien affirmée par bruno le maire
oui on va sortir du quoi qu'il en coûte
face et on sait travailler on savait
très bien que c'était une période
transitoire donc on passera du quoi
qu'il en coûte à au cas par cas et c'est
normal puisqu'il faudra continuer
d'accompagner les entreprises qui sont
encore encore en difficulté de par cette
crise sanitaire et celles qui ont pu
rebondir et elles sont nombreuses et je
précise quand même que olivier dussopt
pts annoncé le ministre des comptes
publics on est à peu près à 40 milliards
du fonds de solidarité qui a permis
aussi aux entreprises de de s'en sortir
est de maintenir une activité importante
moi je sors je sors d'un déjeuner avec
le medef des hauts-de-seine à l'instant
et je peux vous dire que ils sont très
contents aujourd'hui
du bilan du gouvernement du quoi qu'il
en coûte qui leur a permis effectivement
de tenir aujourd'hui la priorité pour
les entreprises françaises c'est pas
c'est pas d'avoir des subventions de
l'état c'est de faire en sorte de
pouvoir recruter parce qu'il ya un
problème en france de recrutement les
jalousies à un certain nombre de
secteurs notamment l'hôtellerie
restauration où on a on a effectivement
des grosses difficultés mais
effectivement pas que pas que
l'hôtellerie restauration et on a aussi
une multiplication depuis de plus de 400
% des contrats courts depuis dix ans et
donc il faut aussi une nécessité de
sortir de la précarité un certain nombre
de salariés est de faire en sorte que
les entreprises qui vont bien puisse
maintenant proposer des contrats plus
sécurisant pour pour les salariés et
qu'on sorte de cette précarité salariale
qui était important depuis dix ans il ya
des réformes économiques les objectifs
économiques et sociaux à atteindre est
aussi l'objectif de redresser les
dépenses publiques et la question des
comptes publics des comptes des
retraites a été posée on ne sait pas
encore vraiment si la réforme des
retraites va être mis sur la table par
le gouvernement jean castex a dit pour
l'instant les conditions ne sont pas
réunies mais à l'elysée et y ait encore
des discussions laurence rossignol est
ce qu'il faut mettre cette réforme sur
la table car les comptes de retraites
sont peut-être un peu inquiétant mais
moi j'imagine pas que le premier
ministre ait une parole qui serait
différente de celle de l'elysée enfin
j'aime pas trop ce que c'est qu'il
disait moi les essais pas une personne
ou alors c'est les entourages fameuse
entourage du président les visiteurs du
soir je ne sais pas qui premier ministre
c'est quand même celui qui charrie de
contre la politique du gouvernement est
de la france premier nizic n'y aura pas
de réforme des retraites j'imagine qu'à
pas de dissonances warsi même si
maintenant les couacs sont entre
l'elysée et matignon ont tout ce qu'on a
entendu entre 2012 et 2017 sur les
couacs je trouve que là on est vraiment
très indulgent donc je pense que c'est
ces prêts ministre a dit ça c'est une
décision raisonnable parce que la
réforme des retraites d'abord été pas
souhaité elle pose énormément de
problèmes de difficultés elle était elle
allait atteindre le niveau des retraites
pour un grand nombre de retraités
allonger la durée de travail dans un
mécanisme qui est déjà compliquée ce que
je regarde c'est que soyons clairs la le
gouvernement effectivement on se
rappelle le quoi qu'il en coûte fait que
le président de la république et le
premier ministre ont fait le choix
d'investir beaucoup d'argent public pour
sauver l'économie française c'était pas
là ce n'était pas le premier choix leur
premier choix ses épaules que vides
c'était l'adaptation à marche forcée de
la france à la dérégulation et à la
mondialisation libérale c'était limitera
libéralisme et se sont trouvés bien
embêté dans leur projet ultra libérale
c'est que le la crise sanitaire avec ses
effets économiques
étaient pas compatibles parce que la
crise sanitaire nous a appris c'est
qu'en fin de compte le libéralisme ne
nous protège et pas en cas de coup dur
or les coups durs vont être maintenant
beaucoup plus fréquent qu'ils n'étaient
auparavant en particulier à cause du
dérèglement climatique et de toutes les
questions sanitaires donc il ya là un
coup d'arrêt à une orientation mais je
n'ai pas vu qu'elle était la nouvelle
orientation je me méfie des conversion
tardive et je ne suis pas sûr que le
présent un public soit converti un
véritablement la régulation la puissance
publique remontée l'industrie remonté la
france tout ce qu'il a d'un certain
point de vue conduit à démanteler
appartement il a été ministre d'économie
et des finances parce que le bilan de
même affront il commencera en 2017 et
c'est une ancienne ministre qui vous dit
croyez moi ils commencent dès lors le
mental laissant d'entrer au gouvernement
moi j'avais lâché d'un certain point de
vue la chance d'être dans le pôle social
on me regardait comme être une miss
dépensière parce qu'effectivement j'ai
dépensé de l'argent pour la famille
l'enfance et des femmes mais à ce qui se
passait à bercy je n'en suis plus
solitaire depuis fort longtemps et le
présente le bilan demain le maquereau et
commence en 2014 dont on connaît son
orientation après le pire est à venir
pour les français et le pire c'est le
deuxième quinquennat benjamin morel si
jamais cette réforme des retraites est
enterré en tout cas pour ce quinquennat
est ce que emmanuel macron va perdre son
image de réformateur de l'économie le
problème c'est qu'il faut comprendre qu
emmanuel macron est pas élu sur une
densité politique lorsque vous êtes élu
sous l'étiquette parti socialiste où l
air vous avez toute la tradition
gaulliste ou socialiste qui fait que ben
vous avez un électorat captif attaché à
une forme de tradition ce que fait
emmanuel macron et bien c'est qu'ils
auront avec ça il construit une image
qui va être une image une forme de
mystique du réformateur qui arrivent au
pouvoir sur l'idée d'une réforme etc
d'où le fait qu emmanuel macron tout au
long de son quinquennat a été contraint
en réalité de donner des gages à son
propre électorat et aux électorats qu'il
voulait alpagué sur justement cette
question de la réforme d'ailleurs quand
vous prenez les conclusions des jets les
jeux ou de l'aco vide voyez qu'il
ressort des réformes qui était déjà dans
les tuyaux pour montrer que grosso modo
et bien il continuer à réformer tout en
répondant aux crises donc là vous avez
quelque chose qui aujourd'hui handicapé
emmanuel macron parce qu'en effet la
situation aujourd'hui n'est pas ouverte
pour une réforme des retraites pour
plusieurs raisons vous avez une opinion
qui est relativement à bout et qui a
besoin de protection et une enquête cap
a été beaucoup commentée mais qui a
extrêmement intéressante du 1er juillet
de l'ifop pour les échos qui montrait
que le terme réforme qui était connotée
à 70% positivement 2017 et est
aujourd'hui connoté à 49% positivement
et un vrai effondrement sur cet aspect
là et sur d'autres aspects relatifs aux
réformes de l'autre côté vous avez avec
la réforme des retraites quand vous
prenez les enquêtes d'avant l'aco vide
et bien une vraie rupture au sein même
de l'électorat macro ni c'est à dire que
vous aviez une partie cet électorat qui
était en rupture de ban vis-à-vis de
cette réforme ce qu'il ne faut
évidemment absolument pas faire la
veille d'une présidentielle
par ailleurs dernier point est bien
emmanuel macron à gouverner en temps de
crise et aujourd'hui est bien la forme
d'accalmie qui semble se dessiner avec
une va dire une sortie de crise de l'aco
vide qui semble se dessiner même s'il
faut être prudent et bien et plutôt à
porter à son crédit si jamais vous avez
une nouvelle crise qui se produit est
bien le président qui tente aujourd'hui
d'apparaître comme la figure
d'unification deviennent figure qui
vante et ça évidemment c'est perdre tout
crédit d'un chef de l'état en temps de
crise c'est très important pour un chef
de l'état qui se représente à sa propre
succession alors on va parler des
mesures sociales qui ont été annoncées
pour cette fin de quinquennat par le
gouvernement le président la république
veut mettre en oeuvre veut mettre en
oeuvre un revenu d'engagement des jeunes
il veut également renforcer cette
cinquième branche de la sécurité sociale
qui doit lutter contre la dépendance à
ce sera dans le budget de la sécurité
sociale et puis le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé olivier
ferrand a annoncé la contraception
gratuite pour les moins de 25 ans avant
de vous donner la parole on va voir ce
qu'on pense à la sénatrice communiste
laurence cohen qui est à votre micro
ch'ti jourdain ouï laurence cohen
bonjour je merci d'être avec nous sur le
volet social cette rentrée s'annonce
assez fort a notamment avec ce revenu
d'engagement pour les jeunes qui maniait
le maquereau on va présenter dans les
jours dans les semaines qui viennent
c'est une rentrée qui commence sur la
jambe gauche pour le gouvernement vous
vous félicitez peut-être alors moi je ne
dirais pas que ça commence par là la
jambe gauche du gouvernement je dirais
qu effectivement c'est une rentrée très
attendue et les syndicats sont mobilisés
il ya d'ailleurs une manifestation le 5
octobre parce que il y à de grosses
difficultés au niveau du pouvoir d'achat
de la population d'une manière générale
ils sont touchés bien sûr les jeunes les
femmes les plus précaires mais aussi les
classes moyennes donc effectivement il
faut que le gouvernement produisent des
actes et on l'attend contre la santé
très concrètement dans les semaines dans
le mois qui suit sociale sur le front
social j'attends déjà qu'ils abandonnent
toutes ces mauvaises réformes je pense à
celles concernant les chômeurs déjà dans
un premier temps voilà jeu j'attends
également qu'il qu'il abandonne
totalement la réforme des retraites
alors il ya eu des annonces de ce mois
là du premier ministre mais il faut
rester toujours très très vigilants et
j'attends surtout et bien qu'ils donnent
un coup de pouce conséquent au smic
parce que effectivement aujourd'hui nous
demandons avec l'ensemble des syndicats
une revalorisation du smic nous nous
demandons qu'il soit porté à 1800 euros
brut et ça veut dire la responsabilité
du gouvernement mais ça veut dire aussi
que le medef doit augmenter tous les
salaires est en avance pour l'instant
comment qu'est ce qui coince qu'est ce
qui coince et la volonté politique c'est
toujours une histoire de volonté
politique on a on est quand même encore
dans la pandémie il ya des salaires qui
sont très très bas il ya de grosses
difficultés il ya beaucoup de
précarisation il ya eu les premiers de
corvée 1 et notamment les premières de
corvée mais j'attends que les salaires
soient augmentés et par exemple ce
serait un acte vraiment important honni
pour le gouvernement de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait l'égalité salariale entre
les femmes et les hommes laurence r j'en
ai pas entendu parler appris aujourd'hui
que la contraception allait désormais
être gratuite en france pour les femmes
jusqu'à 25 ans contre 18 jusque là
j'imagine que vous vous félicitez de
cette annonce de cette mesure qu'ils
arrivent écoutez moi j'ai justement un
esprit qui est un esprit critique c'est
à dire que effectivement je suis du côté
de celles et de ceux qui souffrent du
fait de la crise et de la politique
gouvernementale qui fait des cadeaux
faramineux à ceux qui n'en ont pas
besoin et qu'ils taxent toujours les
plus pauvres dont contient une mesure
qui est positive et je me bats pour la
contraception je me bats pour le droit à
l'avortement je me bats pour tout une
amélioration du droit des femmes d'une
manière générale donc je salue cette
cette mesure qui a été annoncé par le
ministre verront donc un bon point quand
même pour le gouvernement cette rentrée
alors un bon point pour le gouvernement
mais vous avez vu j'ai quand même
décerné beaucoup de mauvais points parce
que la tante des populations c'est
vraiment de booster le pouvoir d'achat
et pour ça c'est d'augmenter les
salaires et d'augmenter le smic merci
beaucoup laurence cohen merci d'avoir
répondu à mes questions merci à vous
merci steve r oui c'est c'est la rentrée
on commence déjà à décerner des bons et
des mauvais points à examiner la comédie
vous faites partie du mouvement ou du
parti territoire de progrès qui
représente l'ailé gauche de la majorité
présidentielle vous saluer ces mesures
sociales qui arrive en fin de
quinquennat oui on les salue et puis on
a été à l'initiative de certaines
d'entre elles et par l'inter milan
attend notamment des manuels jargon et
d'elisabeth bornes sur la question du
revenu d'engagement sur effectivement ça
ne faisait clairement pas l'unanimité au
sein de la majorité il ya une bataille
un arbitrage on est aussi là pour ça
pour être force de proposition on est
dans l'apport de force et pas dans le
rapport de force au sein de la majorité
et donc effectivement c'est notre rôle
aussi au sein de la majorité
présidentielle de pouvoir faire des
propositions puis moi je voudrais réagir
aussi sur ce qui a été dit il ya à la
fois ce qui va arriver et notamment le
revenu d'engagement la contraception
gratuite pour les femmes de moins de 25
ans qui paraît d'ailleurs hallucinant
qu'on n'est pas encore en 2021 cette
possibilité là et que certaines femmes
soit en précarité sûr sûr sûr cette
question de la contraception donc mais
ça c'est donc une avancée mais il ya
aussi tout ce qui a été fait jusqu'à
maintenant moi je pense aux 1 6 million
de jeunes qui ont été embauchés avec le
plan un jeune une solution d'elisabeth
baume je pense au reste à charge 0 sur
le dentaire l'optique et l'auditif je
pense à la baisse de la taxe
d'habitation qui a touché avant tout les
plus bas revenus tous à 7 sur des
mesures sociales d'accompagnement les
repas à 1 euro pour les boursiers
pendant notamment à la pandémie et qu'on
a souhaité effectivement et qui a eu un
arbitrage parce qu'effectivement le leur
pain and euro n'était pas forcément
quelque chose qui devait perdurer pour
les boursiers et on a réussi à l'obtenir
qui puisse être
maintenu en tout cas pour l'ensemble des
bourses et pour tout ça ce sont des
mesures sociales d'accompagnement des
des plus bas revenus et donc ça il faut
le mettre aussi au crédit du
gouvernement alors précisément sur la
conception gratuite pour les femmes de
moins de 25 ans laurence rossignol je
m'adresse à l'ancienne
contraception pas conception pendant
cette journée
gratuite pour les femmes de moins de 25
ans laurence rossignol vous étiez à la
ministre en charge des familles des
droits des femmes et de l'enfance sous
françois hollande vous saluer cette
mesure symbolique est forte emmanuel
macron bas j'espère qu'elle n'est pas
que ça mais c'est pas simplement un
effet d'annoncé alors peut-être un tout
petit peu de précision jeu qu'on va
attendre d'ailleurs amplement demande du
projet loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale aujourd'hui les pilules 1ère
2ème génération et les contraceptifs
sont gratuit jusqu'à 18 ans dans les
mineures ensuite ils sont pris en charge
par la sécurité sociale donc à 65% donc
que propose le gouvernement c'est que
pour les 18 25 il soit pris en charge à
100 % 5 un ticket modérateur les
mutuelles n'y a plus besoin d'avoir une
mutuelle je m'interroge sur les pilules
troisième et quatrième générations qui
ne sont pas prises en charge par la
sécurité sociale est ce qu'elles vont
rester à l'extérieur du dispositif
et puis j'aurais fait un petit message à
m e olivier ferrand c'est très très bien
j'applaudis des deux mains et sans
hésitation mais il faudrait pas que ce
soit une mesure alternative à
l'allongement de deux semaines des
délais dit vg qui ont été votées à
l'assemblée nationale qui sont demandés
par sa propre majorité et sur lequel
alors là c'est emmanuel macron qui
lui-même qui bloque l'elysée ayman
conquête absolument hostile et qui l'a
fait savoir parce que là contrat c'est
la gratuité de la contraception
n'a qu'un faible impact en fait sur le
recours à l'ivg et g je rappelle
toujours que ce soit les deux tiers des
femmes qui ont recours à une ivg sont
déjà sous contraceptif c'est une autre
histoire il faudrait pas essayé de nous
de nous proposer ou de mettre en place
le 100 % pur refusé d'allonger les
délais dit vg qui répondent à une autre
urgence sociale c'est toutes les femmes
en dépassement de délais pour des
raisons diverses quelque chose que j'ai
pas le temps d'exposer ici donc c'est
pas la gratuité contre l'allongement des
délais on veut les deux la gratuité et
l'allongement des délais l'autre mesure
sociale elle concerne les jeunes avec ce
revenu d'engagement des jeunes annoncées
par le président de la république alors
on n'a pas encore tous les détails de ce
revenu il devrait concerner et bien les
jeunes sans formation sans emploi les
jeunes travailleurs précaires jean
françois husson c'est une bonne mesure
au niveau économique et social ce revenu
mme oda blanche attend de voir vous
savez moi je parle de ce que je connais
on manque d'information mais je veux
redire
le défi qu'on a relevé aujourd'hui
plutôt que de donner à priori d'accorder
plus tôt aux revenus d'engagement il
faut tout faire pour améliorer la
formation et pour faire en sorte que
l'emploi pour le plus grand nombre pour
pas dire pour tous soit au rendez vous
et ça n'est pas le cas je le redis on a
on a aujourd'hui on est dans une année
en porte à faux on a beaucoup d'emplois
qui ne sont pas pourvus de tous les
niveaux dans de nombreux secteurs
d'entreprise faut vraiment changer un
hôtel restauration enfin on en a parlé
et matin midi et soir mais c'est dans
tous les domaines jeu en ce moment je
rencontre beaucoup d'entreprises notent
des ingénieurs des formations des bac +
3 à bac + 4 on en manque et aujourd'hui
vous avez déjà l'entreprise qui vous
disent écoutez ben nous on préfère avoir
des ags enfin c'est à des mets mais ils
sont interpellés parce que dans le même
temps ils regardent les charges sociales
et ils disent mais on a une protection
sociale qui aujourd'hui comment dire je
ne réponds plus bien à la situation dans
laquelle on est donc il faut faire
attention et je pense que le problème
grands efforts il doit être mis là
dessus le travail doit trouver sa juste
récompense il doit d'être à moyens
d'ailleurs dévolu et regardez le
parcours aujourd'hui professionnelle des
jeunes et des moins jeunes eh ben on
fait 5 10 métiers ce qui n'était pas le
cas avant ça il faut l'intégrer pas ce
que ça veut dire qu'il faut pouvoir
avoir des accompagnements de formation
il faut redonner de la capacité il faut
investir dans l'humain enfin honnêtement
les salaires c'est au bénéfice des
hommes est là au moins vous vous donnez
d'intéressement vous délai à la
participation on en a impérativement
besoin pour conclure rapidement benjamin
morel l'enjeu de cette fin de
quinquennat en vue de la présidentielle
pour emmanuel macron c'est cette valeur
travail alors c'est pas que la valeur
travail aujourd'hui bien malin celui qui
dit à qui arrivera à dire et qui
arrivera après dire sur quoi va se faire
la campagne d'ici quelques mois pour
l'instant les choses sont illisibles ce
que l'on peut dire à ce stade là c'est
que malgré tout vous avez une forme de
radicalisation de l'opinion une
radicalisation de l'opinion sur les
questions économiques et sociales on dit
beaucoup qui a une droitisation
d'opinion faut faire attention en
réalité sur les enjeux économiques vous
avez plus tôt aujourd'hui une
prédominance des tests de gauche avec
une très très forte réorientation
aujourd'hui d'une partie de l'opinion
sur les thèses en effet sur les
questions migratoires sur les questions
identitaires là vous avez plutôt une
réorientation à droite tout ça peut
créer un mélange assez détonnant avec
aujourd'hui une situation dans l'opinion
qui est classique en temps de crise vous
avez des valeurs d'opinion qui bouge et
vous avez des intentions de vote qui
sont gelées jusqu'au jour où l'opinion
se réveille et ce sera le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à ce
débat dans un instant les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement au sénat
vont commencer et on va se diriger dans
la tribune de presse de l'hémicycle du
sénat avec vous quand un call mais quels
sujets vont marquer cette séance est
bien alex la toute première question va
être posée par eliane assassi la
présidente du groupe communiste sur est
bien la question du pouvoir d'achat des
français et vous le savez on l'a répété
déjà toute l'année dernière lorsque
c'est un président de groupe qui
s'adresse et bien au gouvernement c'est
le premier ministre qui répond donc on
attend tout de suite une prise de parole
de jean castex c'est parti pour cette
séance
[Musique]
excuser l'absence du président larcher
qui est en déplacement dans le gard je
salue également notre nouveau collègue
monsieur thierry magnin sénateur de la
seine-saint-denis qui remplace philippe
dallier
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue monsieur maignien l'ordre du
jour appelle les questions d'actualité
au gouvernement je vous rappelle que la
séance est retransmise en direct sur
public sénat et sur notre site internet
au nom du bureau du sénat j'appelle
chacun de vous mes chers collègues a
observé au cours de nos échanges l'une
des valeurs essentielles du sénat le
respect qu'il s'agisse du respect des
uns et des autres ou de celui du temps
de parole merci
la parole est à madame eliane assassi à
la présidente assassi pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes pour deux minutes bien sûr
monsieur le président messieurs prenez
miss mais chaque collègue malgré la
crise sanitaire les français ont
continué à s'enrichir vient de se
féliciter bruno le maire mais de quel
français par le fil des patrons du cac
40 qui ont vu leur rémunération annuelle
augmenter de 1,5 million d'euros en
moyenne pour atteindre près de 5,3
millions d'euros en 2021 des
actionnaires qui vont voir leurs
dividendes bondir à plus de 50 milliards
d'euros en 2020 alors que les plans de
licenciements se succèdent surtout au
sein d'entreprises qui ont reçu des
aides massives de l'état ou encore des
500 familles les plus fortunées de
france qui ont vu leur patrimoine doublé
depuis le début du quinquennat si c'est
de celà dota parler monsieur le maire il
a raison par contre ce n'est pas la
réalité pour la très grande majorité des
ménages et des 10 millions de personnes
en situation de pauvreté ou de précarité
ménages qui subissent de plein fouet les
trois augmentations pour le gaz en trois
mois la hausse du prix du carburant et
ce n'est pas fini car le prix de
l'électricité augmentent à la fin de
l'année comme le dit mon ami fabien gay
si les salaires augmentent et comme les
tarifs de l'énergie tout le monde pour s
acheter un écran plan ménages qui
subissent enfin dans cette période de
rentrée scolaire
hausse du prix des matières premières du
prix des denrées alimentaires de
première nécessité mais aussi de
l'augmentation des loyers comme le
souligne france stratégie les dépenses
contraintes pèsent toujours plus dans le
budget des ménages monsieur le premier
ministre
améliorer le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens
c'est une urgence êtes vous prêt à
augmenter significativement le chimique
a débloqué le point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires et à contraindre le medef
a augmenté les salaires ne pensez vous
pas que les 6% de croissance ou
féliciter devrait profiter à celles et
ceux qui tout au long de cette crise
sanitaire ont fait beaucoup de
sacrifices et non pas aux plus riches
aux actionnaires soit merci
merci la parole qu'on produit weenee ce
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
madame la présente à sacy merci de
m'interroger pour cette reprise de
l'activité du sénat sur cette question
effectivement très importante du pouvoir
d'achat
si importante mais très difficile alors
pour donner plus de crédit à la réponse
que je vais m'efforcer de vous faire
vous expliquant ce que fait le
gouvernement dans la matière madame j'ai
juste veiller d'autant que je n'étais
pas en fonction
mis un petit coup dans le rétroviseur
pour l'information du sénat
le pouvoir d'achat puisque tel est
l'objet de votre question le pouvoir
d'achat de nos concitoyens j'ai pris
depuis 2010 année à tenait prêt à aider
son évolution ces chiffres publics et
transparents entre 2010 et 2016
l'augmentation annuelle moyenne a été de
+0 53%
l'augmentation annuelle moyenne depuis
2010 est et jusqu'à 2019 inclus je vais
venir à la crise évidemment
l'augmentation annuelle moyenne du
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens a été
de + 1,9 le décor est planté
oui oui oui je sais ce que sont des
moyennes même enfin wada +0 53 plus 1,9
en 2020
année tournant évidemment puisque
survenue de cette crise sanitaire qui a
détruit beaucoup de notre richesse
nationale et qui a donc impacté la
situation économique et surtout sociale
de nos concitoyens comme vous l'avez
rappelé je veux quand même indiqué au
sénat puisque désormais ces données sont
elles aussi public que grâce aux efforts
décidées par le gouvernement et votées
par la représentation nationale le
pouvoir d'achat en france
a progressé peu madame la présence n'a
progressé de 0,2 pour ça quand il a
diminué dans la plupart des pays de
l'union européenne c'est pas des
chiffres de jean castex au des chiffres
vérifiables par vous tous et je veux
vous dire aujourd'hui
que ce que nous prévoyons pour 2021 je
n'ai évidemment pas de chiffres c'est
une hausse du pouvoir d'achat
que j'espère ma réponse est évidemment
public autour voire supérieure à + 1,5
pour cent et pourquoi dames et messieurs
pourquoi le pouvoir d'achat a beaucoup
diminué son augmentation 6 tu m'exprimer
ainsi mais a quand même augmenté en 2020
pourquoi il augmentera encore plus à
2021 parce que nous avons évité à
l'activité économique de ce pays de
s'effondrer et que nous travaillons sur
le fait que la croissance et c'est le
cas sur la plus vigoureuse aujourd'hui
en france parmi les pays de la zone euro
c'est parce que nous travaillons plus
c'est parce qu'il n'ya plus d'emploi
c'est ça la première arme en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens
j'ajoute que pendant toute la crise et
je sais que je prend trop de temps déjà
pour vous répondre nous avons pris toute
une série de dispositions en faveur des
plus démunis est des plus précaires que
nous avons eu l'occasion de décrire de
détailler à plusieurs reprises devant le
sénat et en cette rentrée j'ai reçu les
partenaires sociaux je savais que je
suis particulièrement attachée au
dialogue social vous avez posé la
question du smic le smic son évolution
est prévue par la loi
nous verrons bien comment évolue
l'inflation je n'exclus pas même si
l'inflation en france est inférieur à ce
qu'elle est là encore c'est un bon
indicateur en moyenne de la zone euro en
ce moment nous n'excluons pas
effectivement qu'il y ait une
revalorisation automatique du smic nous
verrons bien
compte tenu de l'évolution des prix
avant le 1er janvier prochain mais mais
madame avec les partenaires sociaux je
leur ai proposé que l'on travaille
surtout sur les métiers sur les branches
ou les minima sont les plus faibles et
en particulier il y en a encore vous le
savez où ces minima de branche sont
inférieurs au smic à la fois pour des
questions de voir d'achat pour
travailler sur l'attractivité des
métiers correspondants raison pour
laquelle nous souhaitons on va y arriver
que des négociations de branche sourds
par exemple pour les hôtels cafés
restaurants quand de graves difficultés
de recrutement et nous n'excluons pas
que la question des salaires pas la
seule par la seule soit une de ses
causes il n'est pas question je vous le
dis madame d'augmenter le point d'indicé
il n'y a pas plus injuste en revanche
vous verrez dans le projet de loi de
finances pour 2022 dont vous aurez à
débattre prochainement que nous faisons
des actions pour les agents de catégorie
c c'est à dire ceux qui le sont le moins
rémunérés dans la fonction publique
comme vous le savez et que dire de
l'impact pouvoir d'achat des mesures du
ségur la santé qui vont également se
déployer cette fois ci dans le cadre du
plfss pour 2022 je termine pardon
d'avoir été trop long mais la question
était extrêmement importante et ça ne
m'étonne pas que vous l'ayez poser en
vous disant chère madame que je suis
personnellement et beaucoup d'attention
l'impasse de l'évolution des prix
notamment de l'énergie vous avez cité en
particulier l'électricité et le gaz je
suis ça très de très près et nous
verrons en fonction d'évolutions si nous
devons prendre des dispositions et si
nous devons le faire nous le ferons
merci monsieur le voyagiste la parole
est maintenant aux présidents patients
pour le groupe du rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendants
sur le président monsieur le premier
ministre les dames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues
la clause de sauvegarde des recettes
fiscales et domaniale qui doit garantir
aux communes et opci un niveau minimum
de ressources pour faire face à la crise
de covile 19 n'a pas joué correctement
son rôle dans les départements
d'outre-mer
110 millions d'euros tel était le
montant estimé est annoncée le 29 mai
2020 par edouard philippe alors premier
ministre à l'arrivée à peine cinq cent
mille euros ont été en fait mobiliser
pour seulement 7 communes ultramarines
qui plus est tous tendus rembourser tout
ou partie de l'acompte versé en 2020
pour un montant total de 15 millions
d'euros c'est le cas de saint denis et
saint paul à la réunion et de fort de
france en martinique qui doivent
reverser plus de 1,4 million d'euros
chacune
cela signifierait-il qu'elles n'ont pas
subi de baisse de leurs recettes
fiscales en 2020
oui pourtant aisément subi et de façon
significative mais les critères choisis
pour mobiliser la clause de sauvegarde
les ânes en exclu
j'avais plaidé lors des débats du plfr 3
de 2020 pour un traitement différencié
des autres maires en prenant notamment
la seule année 2010 9 comme référence
pour le calcul des compensations et non
pas la moyenne des recettes fiscales des
années 2010 à 2019 les amendements bien
qu'adoptée ici au sénat n'ont pas été
conservés dans la version définitive du
texte au final il n'est pas étonnant que
les deux hommes aient si peu mobilisé la
clause de sauvegarde si l'on prend
l'exemple de la guyane mon territoire
les collectivités affichent un recul net
de 15 millions d'euros soit 5 % entre
2000 19 et 2020 pour les seules recettes
fiscales prises en compte pour cette
compensation mais avec la moyenne
triennale comme référence elles
ressortent avec un surplus de 10
millions et ne sont plus éligibles à la
clause de sauvegarde le gouvernement
avait annoncé qu'il ne saurait y avoir
de compensation à l'euro près et avec
ses critères c'est effectivement le
qu'on en voit bien ici il n'y a pas eu
de compensation et que la clause de
sauvegarde n'a pas fonctionné ceci est
d'autant plus pénalisant que les
collectivités d'outre-mer se trouve dans
une situation financière
structurellement dégradé à l'image du
contexte socio-économique et son style
évolue madame la ministre que compte le
faire le gouvernement pour y remédier
voilà la parole est à madame nadia
ministre délégué chargé de la ville
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président georges patient permettez moi
d'abord d'adresser mes encouragements
aux ultramarins qui affronte en ce
moment même et depuis plusieurs semaines
une vague de kovy de sans précédent et
où des restrictions restent en vigueur
afin de casser cette progrès la
progression de l'épidémie cette crise
met en tension les budgets des communes
qui bénéficient de clause de sauvegarde
financé par l'état ces mécanismes sont
conçus pour aider les communes qui
perdent le plus de recettes par rapport
à une référence sur trois ans j'entends
votre peau proposition d'une référence
dérogatoires pour les communes guyanaise
nous n'avons pas retenu qu'elle aurait
car elle aurait créé une rupture
d'égalité
cependant des aides ont bien été versées
17 communes des départements d'outre-mer
dont deux grilles à l'aise ont reçu près
de 3 millions de compensations fiscales
etc le calcul qui a été fait selon
l'octroi de mer qui n'a baissé que de 4
% entre 2019 et 2020 je rappelle que ce
filet de sécurité se prolonge en 2021 et
c'est notamment grâce à un amendement
sénatorial que vous avez voté et qu'il
s'applique également les deux années aux
pertes d'octroi de mer et de taxes sur
les carburants des collectivités supra
communal je rappelle aussi que l'état
mobilise 62 millions d'euros de
subventions d'investissements
supplémentaires dans le plan de relance
pour les projets des communes
d'outre-mer dont 8 millions d'euro en
guyane au delà de la crise je rappelle
que sur la base de votre rapport de 2019
nous avons engagé un rattrapage des
dotations de péréquation des communes
des départements d'outre-mer
initialement prévu sur cinq ans nous
avons décidé de le mener à bien sur
quatre 4 ans les résultats sont là par
exemple la dgf des communes guyanaise a
progressé de 17,6 millions d'euros
depuis 2010 est et je vous annonce que
ce mouvement va continuer au même rythme
dans le plf 2022 comme vous le voyez
monsieur le président patients le
gouvernement est à l'écouté des élus
guyanais et ultramarins comme il est à
l'écouté de tous les territoires elle
continuera évidemment de l'être
très bien la parole est maintenant
monsieur victorin lurel pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
beaucoup trop de territoire et de
famille en hexagone comme en outre-mer
vivent toutes choses égales par ailleurs
les mêmes souffrances et les mêmes
peines les connaissent peu ou prou le
même dénouement des hôpitaux la même
fatigue des soignants la même suffisance
et effectifs et la même surdité
gouvernementale le point commun à ces
situations est donc bien la nature la
pertinence et l'efficacité de la
politique sanitaire que vous conduisez
cette quatrième vague n'est pas entré
par effraction dans nos vies elle est
aussi la conséquence d'un sous
investissement chronique depuis des
décennies dans notre système de soins et
d'un manque d'anticipation manifeste en
hexagone et qui a connu son acné dans
les outre mer oui votre politique porte
une atteinte grave aux libertés
perverti la démocratie et installe
durablement une société du contrôle
surtout elle ne résout en rien les
carences et la désorganisation de notre
système de soins le pass sanitaire
contre lequel nous avons voté est devenu
l'alpha et l'oméga de votre politique
vaccinale il va bientôt s'appliquer à
nos adolescents
avec les difficultés que l'on imagine
soyons réalistes les françaises et les
français ne pourront supporter plus
longtemps cette vie fait d'interdît et
de restrictions pour notre part sur ses
bancs notre position est claire et
connue de tous c'est l'obligation
vaccinale
progressive universelle et gratuite
nous avons d'ailleurs pris une
initiative de rip pour sauver l'hôpital
public et déposé une proposition de loi
sur l'obligation vaccinale pour votre
part que comptez vous faire pour
l'avenir comptez vous maintenir encore
longtemps ce pass sanitaire profondément
inégalitaire et intrusif quand
comptez-vous en forte pour l'obligation
vaccinale seule mesure de nature à
concilier les libertés individuelles et
la protection de tous quand comptez-vous
enfin présenté une politique sanitaire
et hospitalière repensez à l'aune de
cette crise à même de réarmer notre
offre de son
merci la parole est à monsieur olivier
veyrat milices des solidarités de la
santé
monsieur le sénateur victorin lurel a
pas si longtemps de ça nous avons été
collègues vous et moi
au sein d'une même majorité sous un
gouvernement précédent si le sénateur
je n'ai pas souvenir et je respecte
infiniment de travail de mes
prédécesseurs notamment de la
prédécesseure marisol touraine dans le
mandat précédent qui a fait beaucoup de
choses et qui a fait notamment ce
qu'elle a pu pour dégager des moyens
pour l'hôpital monsieur le sénateur je
n'ai pas souvenir et j'ai de la mémoire
que nous ayons décrocher ne serait-ce
que 5% des crédits alloués en plus à
l'hôpital à travers le ségur de la santé
9 milliards d'euros- dose de salaire 19
milliards d'euros de reprise de dettes
investissements pour les hôpitaux en
métropole comme dans les territoires
ultramarins sur le sénateur vous avez
raison il ya eu un retard qui était pris
dans les hôpitaux pâques en outre-mer en
métropole aussi ce retard nous sommes en
train de le combler accompagnez nous
encourager nous vos télés plfss
lorsqu'ils portent ces mesures que vous
vos voeux quelques mois plus tard
vous souligner l'impérieuse nécessité de
la vaccination je prends votre appel à
l'obligation vaccinale comme un appel à
la population guyanaise de se vacciner
elle aussi monsieur le sénateur on peut
débattre de cela je ne dis pas que c'est
une une idée saugrenue et qui ne
mériterait pas un débat plus long
d'ailleurs que les deux minutes qui me
sont accordés mais alors à laquelle je
vous parle il ya 75 % à 70 % de la
population de guyane qui n'est pas
vaccinée j'attends donc avec impatience
la proposition de loi que vous déposerez
pour savoir quelles sont les sanctions
qui s'appliqueront dès lors que cette
loi sera applicable à 70% de la
population de guyane qui n'est pas
vacciné encourager nous à vacciner les
populations de métropole et d'outre-mer
la cinquième la quatrième vague monsieur
le sénateur n'est pas le fait d'une
carence hospitalière ou de services
publics elle est le fait d'un virus
invisible contagieux qui fait des
ravages qui circule partout et dans tous
les pays où ils circulent en revanche on
sait qu'il ya une chose qui lui permet
qui permet d'éviter qu'ils circulent et
qui fasse des ravages la vaccination
monsieur le sénateur la vaccination
merci la parole est maintenant aux
présidents jean claude requier pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen merci monsieur le
président monsieur
dans le contexte exceptionnel que nous
traversons depuis maintenant depuis près
de 18 mois le retour à la vie normale
auquel nous aspirons tous passent aussi
par la reprise de notre économie
l'insee prévoit ici une croissance de 6
1% pour 2021
ce sera malgré tout insuffisant pour
compenser trimestre de croissance perdue
à cause de la pannerie et salue donc le
plan de relance votre gouvernement dans
l'enveloppé tail 100 millions d'euros
qu'elle a contribué à soutenir le
redémarrage des économies en particulier
par le piller cohésion des territoires
dotés de 36 millions d'euros la pétition
publique est ainsi un instrument
efficace de la relance les collectivités
qui représentent 75% de ces
investissements sont en première ligne
pourtant la hausse du coût des matières
premières depuis quelques mois vient
lourdement grevé ses investissements et
une fille née la reprise et l'emploi
ainsi sur le site comment price le prix
l'aluminium a bondi de 30% depuis
janvier celui écrit oddo 1 % celui de
l'acier le 26 à 80% se libérer ces deux
52% et le bois devient rare et cher un
exemple des conséquences parmi tant
d'autres la caravane comme une diode 460
habitants située près du corps le coût
prévisionnel de la construction n'est
que le secteur est passé en quelques
mois des meilleurs cinq cent mille euros
1 million 800 mille huit cent mille
entraînant un surcoût difficiles à
couvrir la commune est à la limite de
ses capacités dans bones
aussi aujourd'hui dans vos projets sont
à l'arrêt voire annulées du fait le coc
qui se mesure au niveau mondial
incidemment ce sont aussi des
entreprises qui sont tous en difficulté
dans le secteur fortement pourvoyeur
d'emplois monsieur le premier ministre
comment le gouvernement compte des ti
dans ce contexte soutenir de façon
exceptionnelle
ces collectivités territoriales merci la
réponse est au premier ministre monsieur
le premier ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs sénateurs monsieur président
tout est juste dans votre question
comme toujours comme toutes les
questions mais effectivement dans les
multiples sujets de la rentrée
dans un contexte dont vous avez quand
même bien voulu rappeler les éléments
très positifs et en particulier la
vigueur de la reprise dont j'espère bien
que dans les tous prochains mois elle
nous permettra
d'apporter un léger correctifs avait pas
ce que vous avez dit de reconstituer le
pib détruits depuis
mars 2020 il faut travailler sur tous
les leviers de la croissance c'est ce
que mon gouvernement s'emploie à faire
mais parmi les sujets de la rentrée il y
en a un
prénationale si je puis dire qui
consiste à dire nous créons des emplois
beaucoup un rythme très largement
supérieurs aux prévisions grâce je le
passe à l'effort des français et à la
politique que nous conduisons mais on a
du mal à pourvoir ces emplois c'est un
premier problème
sur lequel je me suis exprimé hier
et puis un deuxième problème qui lui est
international qui est effectivement le
renchérissement
voir la raréfaction d'un certain nombre
de matières premières vous en avez cité
beaucoup il ne s'est pas complètement
limitatif il n'y a pas que la france
évidemment qui est confronté à ce
phénomène et du coup il était évident
que nos moyens d'action nationaux sont
plus limités néanmoins deux choses
d'abord dès le 15 juin emmanuelle wargon
et bruno le maire ont réuni l'ensemble
des filières en tout cas celles qui ont
été ou qui sont les principalement
impactée par les phénomènes que vous
avez décrit un comité de suivi et de
crise a été constituée et déjà ce comité
a contribué à résoudre ou en tout cas
ténue et certaines situations identifiés
par les fédérations professionnelles
parce que il y avait aussi des hausses
de prix non justifiée sans délai des
surstocks constitué à des fins
spéculatives
et puis des problématiques clients
fournisseurs
deuxièmement nous avons demandé aux
acheteurs publics de l'état
je le dis aussi aux collectivités
locales dans les contrats de commande
publique en cours d'exécution de ne pas
appliquer de pénalités lorsque des
retards de livraison ou d'exécution sont
liées à des envolées de prix des
matières premières ou de pénurie
d'approvisionnement
troisièmement nous essayons d'agir au
plan international et en particulier
l'europe j'ai moi même saisi pour la
question du bois puisque vous savez vous
l'avez cité d'ailleurs dans votre
question on a un
sujet spécifique pour le bois notamment
parce qu'il ya des exportations de
grumes en particulier vers le sud est
asiatique qui sont extrêmement
importantes donc là les mesures
s'agissant de la régulation du commerce
international relève comme le sel c'est
nada commission européenne et il ya une
série de réunions techniques nous
attendons dans les prochains jours ou
semaines des actions de la commission
avant de prendre des mesures nationales
qu'elle pourra nous autoriser à prendre
enfin dernier élément vous avez parlé
monsieur le sénateur de là impact ceci
sur les opérations conduites en maîtrise
d'ouvragé par les collectivités
territoriales
financé par ailleurs par le plan de
relance et je salue le fait que les
collectivités territoriales soutenu par
l'état s'associe massivement à la
relance pour ce qu'on appelle le bloc
communal nous avons choisi vous le savez
toutes et tous de faire des crt e
contrat de relance et principes
écologiques il y en aura partout en
france donc c'est un effort massif
nous réfléchissons et je pourrai bientôt
faire des annonces à ce sujet monsieur
le sénateur pour aller dans le sens de
votre préoccupation a abondé la déchire
la detr qui sont derrière c'est certain
pour en particulier tenir compte des
phénomènes que vous venez à bon droit de
décrire merci
merci la parole est maintenant madame
monique de marco pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
président madame la ministre chaque
collègue
nous voici à la veille de la dernière
rentrée universitaire du quinquennat la
mission d'information menée par le sénat
a présenté un bilan de la condition
étudiante après deux années
universitaires marquait pas la pandémie
elle a mis en évidence les difficultés
déjà présentes et amplifiée par la crise
sanitaire notamment la précarité
matérielle l'accès au logement et à la
santé l' enquête annuelle publiée par
l'unef évalue la hausse du coût de la
vie étudiante à plus de 2 5% par rapport
à l'an dernier il ya plus de 10% par
rapport au début du quinquennat mais en
même temps les aides directes ont baissé
de 39 euros en moyenne par étudiant et
par an alors que ça d'augmenter lors du
mandat précédent
seul un quart des étudiants reçoit une
bourse qui est inférieur à 200 euros
pour la moitié d'entre eux les repas 1
euro pour tous ont permis de lutter
contre la précarité alimentaire y
compris pour les non boursiers nous
regrettons profondément la suppression
de cette mesure qui était pourtant
saluée à l'unanimité
nous souhaitons qu'elles soient
réexaminées
vous avez annoncé l'an dernier lambeau
de 82 psychologue 60 assistante sociale
1600 référent cité u et 20 minutes terre
où en est la réalisation de ces mesures
à la veille de la rentrée universitaire
ces postes seront ils pérennisent et
nous arrivons au dernier projet de loi
de finance du quinquennat c'est le
budget de la dernière chance pour mener
une politique significative et durable à
destination des étudiants
quand et vous mobiliser des financements
pour inciter à la construction de
logements en résidence universitaire et
surtout quand tu es vous intégrez une
réforme significative des bourses dans
le prochain projet de loi de finances
2010 22 comme cela a été promis à
plusieurs reprises au cours du mandat
pour revaloriser les aides et permettent
davantage d'étudiants de les recevoir je
vous remercie merci
madame frédéric vidal ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation
merci monsieur le président mais
la sénatrice de marco d'abord permettez
moi de souhaiter une excellente rentrée
universitaire à l'ensemble des étudiants
c'est rentrée se déroule en ce moment
sur tous les campus de france et je
crois que le plaisir que j'ai pu
constater la semaine dernière à
dunkerque à nîmes
avignon que je suis sûr de voir demain à
toulon ou à marseille le plaisir de se
retrouver le plaisir de retrouver la vie
étudiante et bien et partager autant par
les étudiants que par les enseignants
vous avez raison de le dire les
étudiants ont traversé cette période
avec beaucoup de résilience avec
beaucoup de courage avec beaucoup de
responsabilités on voit qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui plus de 85 % à s'être engagé
dans une procédure vaccinale ce qui nous
permet aussi cette rentrée en présentiel
est ce que je voulais vous dire aussi
c'est que évidemment le gouvernement à
accompagner et va continuer à
accompagner les étudiants 3,3 milliards
d'euros dans le budget 2022 pour la vie
étudiante ça n'avait jamais atteint ce
niveau le maintien contrairement à ce
que vous dites des repas sains euros
pour non seulement les étudiants
boursiers mais aussi tous ceux qui
bénéficient d'aidés et d'accompagnement
par les crous
évidemment le maintien des psychologues
parce que nous savons bien que la
détresse psychologique que certains ont
pu ressentir ne va pas s'arrêter
simplement parce que l'été est passé
c'est l'an dernier 77 mille
consultations de psychologues qui ont
été pris en charge pour l'ensemble des
étudiants
vingt-deux mille emplois dans les
établissements dans les crous qui là
encore sont maintenues de manière à
pouvoir accompagner les étudiants 3,6
millions d'heures de tutorat destiné à
appeler les étudiants pour ne pas qu'il
se sente seul pendant la période de
pandémie et nous savons que nous allons
avoir besoin de continuer tout cela bref
madame la sénatrice je vous rassure le
gouvernement a été présent pour les
étudiants pendant la crise et il
continuera à l'être en espérant
évidemment que cette crise s'atténue et
deviennent derrière nous
merci la parole est maintenant monsieur
pierre jean verzeaux laine pour le
groupe les indépendants république et
territoires
monsieur le président madame la ministre
les événements climatiques de cet été je
parle du niveau des précipitations je
parle des inondations et je parle de
leurs conséquences ont fait monter un
sujet dont on entend parler de plus en
plus
quelle est la politique de gestion des
cours d'eau en france et pour être plus
précis quelles sont les missions
le rôle et la place des agences de l'eau
déjà sur un plan juridique il ya un
absolu besoin un indispensable besoin
clarifications sur les travaux les
aménagements des cours d'eau des fossés
qu'est-ce qu'on a le droit de faire
qu'est-ce qu'on ne peut pas faire qu'est
ce qui relève du régime de la
déclaration qu est-ce qui rélève de
l'autorisation
tout le monde s'y perd y compris les
services de l'état ce qui d'ailleurs dès
fois devrait amener
comment la police de l'eau et de
l'environnement à un peu plus de
souplesse et de et bienveillance sur le
sujet des cours d'eau les compétences
sont nombreuses les interlocuteurs aussi
et on peut constater depuis quelques
temps que l' agence de l'eau sur ce
sujet répond aux abonnés absents et or
l' agence de l'eau devrait être un
partenaire essentiel sur ce sujet en
conseil et de en financement puisque
c'est le partenaire numéro 1 financiers
pour accompagner et soutenir les projets
d'aménagement et les agences de l'eau
sont devenus depuis quelques années deux
méga structure administrative qui se
sont éloignés pour pas dire déconnecté
des interlocuteurs de terrain et des
problématiques locales et elle se
concentre désormais quasi exclusivement
sur la réimplantation sur des grands
sujets sur la biodiversité c'est très
bien c'est indispensable il faut pas
laisser de côté tout ce
faux pas laissés sur le chemin tous ceux
qui subissent les conséquences d'un
manque d'investissement sur ces sujets
madame la ministre au regard de ces
remarques qui remonte des territoires
pouvez-nous nous prêts nous préciser les
missions de l' agence de l'eau en la
matière et comptez vous avancez sur le
mode de gouvernance et notamment sujet
très important sur la composition des
conseils d'administration des agences de
l'eau pour faire une foule une place
plus importante aux représentants des
collectivités locales merci pour vos
réponses la balle est à madame barbara
bombe billy ministre de la transition
écologique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur sénateurs verts hélène je vous
remercie pour cette question qui est
importante parce qu'on est sur un sujet
essentiel vous l'avez dit on a eu
beaucoup d'événements climatiques
extrêmes ces derniers temps et j'adresse
évidemment toute ma solidarité toute la
solidarité du gouvernement aux
françaises et aux français et bien au
delà à tous ceux qui ont été soumis à
ces
à leurs conséquences on sait d'ailleurs
le dérèglement climatique va accroître
la fréquence et l'intensité de ces
événements extrêmes et donc on doit
adapter nos politiques publiques à cette
nouvelle donne on déploie un certain
nombre d'actions et d'ailleurs le
président de la république a eu
l'occasion d'en préciser un certain
nombre lors du congrès de lycéennes qui
est en train de se dérouler puisqu'on le
sait la biodiversité a aussi une
influence sur le réchauffement
climatique tout est lié et ça me
permettra de répondre à une des
questions que vous posiez les agences de
l'eau c'est un des instruments de cette
politique et je suis d'accord avec vous
la complexité des différentes structures
mérite certainement d'être améliorée il
ya eu déjà des pistes dans la loi nôtre
et il faut probablement poursuivre la
réflexion sur la clarification des
missions je vous rappelle que les agents
de l'eau esber notamment contrôler mais
il mène aussi des actions d' expertise
de concertation de sensibilisation à
l'égard des collectivités et nous devons
aussi leur donner les moyens de pouvoir
mener ces actions qui sont importantes
parce que quand on sanctionne il faut
aussi avoir eu le temps de travailler à
améliorer les choses avec les acteurs
concernés pour des agences de l'eau être
aux abonnés absents vous êtes un peu dur
je pense qu'elles sont surtout victimes
de leur succès et d'ailleurs je me
réjouis à ce titre que la prochaine loi
de finances confortent leurs moyens et
permettent aussi de conforter les moyens
du plan de relance
les financements proposés par les
agences de l'eau sont quand même
beaucoup axé sur la biaude sur les lots
sur les l'assainissement notamment il ya
encore beaucoup de financements qui sont
proposés maintenant il ya aussi des
financements sur la biodiversité mais
parce que encore une fois tout est lié
quand on a des esgaulx système qui
fonctionne on a une eau de meilleure
qualité les agences de l'eau doivent
jouer tout son rôle mais je suis
d'accord avec vous sur le fait que le
travail n'est pas terminé on va le
continue
merci la parole est maintenant madame la
présidente de roche pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de la santé ma question
s'adresse à vous ils auraient pu
s'adresser aux eaux également au garde
des sceaux le projet de loi de
bioéthique a été adoptée en juillet lors
de l'examen de ce texte
vous aviez été très clair en fixant des
limites et notamment en désignant la la
grossesse pour la gestation pour autrui
comme une une ligne rouge
infranchissable
de dans l'examen de ce texte bon c'était
une opinion qui était d'ailleurs partagé
par nombre de nos collègues surtout les
rangs qui souhaitait même celles et ceux
qui avaient soutenu l'extension de la
procréation médicale assistée pour les
couples de femmes ou les femmes seules
cette position en effet elle correspond
à des limites
éthiques entre guillemets mais même si
nous avions regretté que ce projet soit
dans une note poétique que le
gouvernement entendait fixer or s'est
tenue récemment un salon auquel selon
désir d'enfant alors loin de moi l'idée
de nier le désir d'enfant mais qui est
partenaire d'entreprises étrangères qui
viennent sur notre territoire faire de
la promotion de la publicité pour des
pratiques à l'étranger certes mais qui
sont tout à fait contraire aux limites
que à la fois le gouvernement et le
parlement ont fixé donc je souhaitais
avoir votre avis sur la tenue de tels
événements sur notre territoire
merci
là par l'état monsieur olivier en me
disais solidarité de la santé
madame la présidente catherine d'europe
d'abord bonne rentrée à vous également
vous m'interrogez sur un salon
spécifique si j'ai bien compris en
région parisienne j'ai pu passer ça
pardon dans la presse à travers
différentes tribunes et prises de
position vous imaginez bien c'est pas un
salon publique organisée par le
gouvernement ou par une collectivité
salon privé qui répondront le droit qui
répand donc au droit privé en matière de
réglementation de deux salons j'ai vu
qu'il y avait pas mal de parrainage
venant de l'étranger par des structures
ou associatives ou privées qui
promeuvent des pratiques qui ne sont pas
autorisés dans le droit français et jeu
parce que je me suis renseigné aussi
j'ai vu qu'il y avait une association
qui avait attaqué en justice ce salon
l'année dernière que la justice ne s'est
pas encore prononcé aujourd'hui de vous
dire si il ya quelque chose qui relève
de l'illégalité ce n'est pas à moi de le
dire c'est à la justice de le dire en
termes d'organisation s'est pas
l'apanage ni les parlementaires ni les
gouvernements mais un événement de droit
privé donc j'ai pas debout plus de
positions sur le salon en tant que tel
et vous rappeler comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même avec justesse madame la
sénatrice que la loi bioéthique elle
entérine de nouveaux droits et
d'ailleurs grâce un nombre de sénatrices
et sénateurs qui se sont mobilisés pour
aussi pour ces nouveaux droits à savoir
le pm la pma pour les couples de femmes
et les femmes seules dont les décrets
sortiront bientôt et qu'elle entérine
aussi l'interdiction là j'ai bien le
droit n'a pas bougé dans la matière donc
tout ce qui va promouvoir sur le
territoire français des pratiques qui
sont irrégulières ou illégal relève
encore une fois d'une saisine de la
justice avec décision à attendre
même la présidente de roche
merci monsieur le ministre savait un peu
que vous me feriez cette réponse là sans
qu'on ait échangé sur le sujet ce que
vous dites est vrai néanmoins il ya eu
une première édition de ce salon
la justice avait été saisie en attendent
toujours la réponse et ça correspond
quand même à cette ambiguïté qu'il y a à
un moment le politique s'efface il ya
des déclarations qui sont faites et et
se produit sur le territoire il y aurait
plein de sujets sur lesquels je pourrais
dire la même chose ou au finalement ce
que ça décrédibilise et ça fragilise
quand même les positions politiques
c'était ce que souhaitait dire mais on
en restera là sur ce débat je souhaite
en revanche signalé le port du du rubans
dorés de septembre en or pour la
sensibilisation cancers de l'enfant est
dire combien les parlementaires nous
souhaitons tous être aux côtés des
petits guerriers et de leurs familles
merci madame la présidente pour ses
propos la parole est maintenant sur
jacques le nay pour le groupe union
centriste
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères je m'exprime ici en
tant que président du groupe d'amitié
france afghanistan est associé à ma
question le président cambon et plus
largement la majorité sénatoriale
près d'un mois après le fiasco du
retrait précités et non concertée des
américains avec ses scènes de panique et
d'horreur un fait s'impose les talibans
sont à nouveau les maîtres de
l'afghanistan le gouvernement a annoncé
hier laisse transparaître une ligne
islamistes durs c'est une réalité
désolante dont il convient de tirer les
conséquences politiques
les premières images du nouveau régime
sont inquiétantes vis-à-vis des femmes
et des activistes mais aussi de ceux qui
ont travaillé pour d'autres
gouvernements pourtant des signes
d'ouverture avaient été donnés notamment
direction des ong
devant cette situation l'europe et la
france ne peuvent se tenir à l'écart
les pays voisins de l'afghanistan avant
déjà leurs pions et ont acté la prise de
pouvoir des talibans
monsieur le ministre pour pouvoir
évacuer ceux qui ne l'ont pas été pour
éviter une répression aveugle pour
protéger les vaincus du panjshir et tous
les afghans pour préserver les acquis
notamment en matière d'éducation et pour
établir notre présence séculaire dans ce
pays nous nous devons de faire jouer
tous les leviers
nous n'avons évidemment aucune garantie
que les talibans respecteront leurs
engagements
mais les mettre au ban de la communauté
internationale
nous priverait à coup sûr de tout moyen
de pression ils contribueraient à les
rapprocher des mouvements jihadistes
internationaux à commencer par al qaïda
monsieur le ministre une fois la
poussière du chaos retombée il nous
appartiendra de définir une nouvelle
stratégie vis-à-vis de l'afghanistan
êtes vous aujourd'hui en mesure de nous
en dessiner les contours
mais si la parole est à monsieur jean
yves le drian ministre de l'europe et
des affaires étrangères monsieur le
sénateur jacques genêt
n'avons pas de dialogue politique avec
les talibans
nous entretenons que des des contacts
opérationnels pragmatique pour faciliter
les opérations d'évacuation
à la fois de nos ressortissants mais
aussi des afghanes et des afghans qui y
ont aidé l'armée française nos propres
services dans le passé et aussi aider à
l'évacuation des afghanes et des afghans
qui sont menacés du fait de leur
engagement de leur métier de leur
profession de leur histoire de leur
combat contre pour le respect des
libertés n'ont pas de dialogue politique
nous entretenons ces discussions
techniques par l'intermédiaire bene
volantes des autorités du qatar
n'ont pu grâce à cela permette
l'exfiltration de 2800 personnes dans
2600 afghane et afghans les jours
derniers en dix jours rendent hommage à
nos équipes qui ont fait un travail
remarquable de sang froid et de courage
et nous sommes en discussion pour
vérifier si lorsque le l'aéroport de
kayes à à kaboul sera réouvert on
pourrait encore procéder à d'autres
défis stration il nous reste quelques
ressortissants quelques ayants droit et
aussi des afghanes des afghans clio se
sont signalés dans leur combat et que
vous-même mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs avaient signalé et nous
suivons tous les cas précisément vous
faites état des déclarations des
talibans nous nous attendons des actes
quand je dis nous c'est pas nous
uniquement la france c'est nous les
européens etc nous le conseil de
sécurité qui s'est réuni à la demande de
la france la semaine dernière et qui a
té par une résolution ces principes le
conseil de sécurité avec le fait que
c'était adoptée à l'unanimité met d
abstention de la chine et la russie mais
néanmoins la résolution est passé il ya
des principes majeurs que nous entendons
voir respecter par les talibans sur la
rupture avec les terrorismes sur le
respect des droits humains et le droit
des femmes sur la libre circulation sans
entrave que ce soit aussi sur le libre
accès des de l'aide humanitaire pour
l'instant le compte n'y est pas et même
au delà de cela la composition de ce que
les taliban appellent le gouvernement
intérimaire du gouvernement provisoire
ne nous donne pas des signes de grand
optimisme dont nous sommes soucieux des
actes des talibans avant de bouger au
delà pas uniquement nous c'est le
principe de base la communauté
internationale merci monsieur le
ministre la parole et maintenat monsieur
rené paul savary pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président en question
porte sur la réforme des retraites
la mère des réformes
si j'ai bien compris
vous avez indiquée le deuxième
renoncement non faut dire que la réforme
qui avait été proposé il ya un an un
système de retraite universel par points
étaient pas forcément adapté à la france
certes calqué sur le modèle suédois qui
leur met d'ailleurs en cause aujourd'hui
bouleverser les choses alors entre tout
changé et rien changer et peut-être une
marge de manoeuvre surtout que si on
abandonne une réforme systémique on est
obligé de se tourner vers des réformes
paramétriques puisque par définition un
système de retraite par répartition
auquel les français sont très attachés
doit être équilibrée je voulais savoir
quelles étaient les intentions du
gouvernement vis-à-vis de cette
préoccupation majeure pour les français
merci la parole est à monsieur laurent
pietrasinski secrétaire d'état chargé
des retraites et de la santé au travail
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices mais sur les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur rené paul savary
d'abord et puis vous le savez la
priorité du gouvernement c'est
d'accompagner la reprise de l'activité
d'ancrer cette relance est de
capitaliser sur les indicateurs
économiques qui il est vrai sont plutôt
positives tant d'ailleurs sur le chômage
que sur la croissance et tout cela grâce
à l'action énergique du gouvernement
depuis le début la crise sanitaire pour
permettre à nos entreprises à garder la
tête hors de l'eau et à nos salariés
d'être protégés je le dis c'est toujours
important vous savez ce sujet des
retraites est un sujet qui me tient à
coeur et qui tient à coeur au président
de la république au gouvernement le
président de la république s'est exprimé
le juillet monsieur le sénateur et a
clairement dit les choses cette réforme
est indispensable il nous faudra la
faire il nous faudra la faire pour des
raisons que vous connaissez bien aussi à
la fois la nécessité de protéger ce
système par répartition parce qu'il
n'est pas à léquilibre ils présentent
des déficits importants et récurrents et
d'eau chaude donc la mettra équilibre
pour assurer la retraite de nos plus
jeunes et et puis aussi parce que il
n'est pas juste ce n'est pas juste il
présente trop de disparités pour
l'ensemble des français il ne tient pas
assez compte de la réalité des travail
qui sont les travaux qui seront réalisés
des activités donc tout cela vous le
savez et nous le réaliserons alors nous
le réaliserons quand elle nous le
réaliserons lorsque la situation
sanitaire sera revenu à la normale et
lorsque la croissance économique sera
définitivement ancré ne vous a pas
échappé qu'il n'y a plus de 2200 de nos
concitoyens qui sont encore en
réanimation aujourd'hui et que la
priorité de ce gouvernement aujourd'hui
c'est d'ancrer la relance qui d'assurer
la protection de la santé nos
concitoyens
merci monsieur savary
merci voilà pas trop de précisions sur
la réforme en tout cas monsieur le
ministre de la retraite vous avez de
l'avenir devant vous simplement on peut
se poser des questions par rapport à nos
personnes âgées quand même on leur à
augmenter le smic à un certain moment la
réforme de la dépendance on la voit pas
venir les inégalités des petites
retraites elles n'ont pas été comblées
alors de deux choses l'une où le nouveau
monde n'aime pas l'ancien monde ou alors
vous avez renoncé à réformer quant aux
circonstances effectivement pour engager
une réforme et dans quelques mois est ce
que la crise sanitaire sera derrière
nous je n'en suis pas entièrement
convaincu avec le mariant dans quelques
mois est ce que nous serons assurés de
une reprise économique stable sûrement
pas dans un contexte mondial difficile
il faudra quand même rembourser le veut
quoi qu'il en coûte et je ne suis pas
sûr que l'attitude des partenaires
sociaux qui vous préoccupent qui nous
préoccupe haillan s'assoupissent ans
lors d'une campagne électorale
en conséquence je pense que quand on ne
veut pas réformer on trouve toujours les
bons prétextes pour ne pas le faire
merci
la parole est maintenant madame
catherine conconne pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je préfère préciser d'emblée
que je vais vous parler de la martinique
ça évitera comme tout à l'heure comme
collègue lurel se voir les ponts sous la
guyane alors qu'il vous parlais de la
guadeloupe alors que la quatrième vague
de kovy 19 continue d'impacter
douloureusement l'amanti n'y ait que des
mesures de confinement sont prises
légitimement pour protéger nos
populations en il en en limitant
également l'accès il faut dès à présent
penser à demain à l'avenir préparer les
conditions d'une reprise de l'économie
qui seule pourra empêcher la crise à la
crise sociale de succéder à la crise
sanitaire j'aimerais vous parler du
tourisme un secteur stratégique est en
plein essor aux antilles et qui
s'enfonce le piment ce 2020 dans une
impasse pris en tenaille entre la
nécessité de maintenir des
investissements indispensables à la
poursuite de l'activité et l'absence
durable de clientèle sans aucune
perspective d'amélioration à moyen terme
vous avez annoncé le prolongement des
dispositifs des d'économies comme le
fonds de solidarité outre-mer c'est une
bonne chose mais les conditions
d'éligibilité font que trop grand nombre
d'entreprises ne peuvent pas y accéder
même chose pour le dispositif d' aide à
la prise en charge des coûts fixes dans
l'hôtellerie et la restauration qui
exclut les entreprises dont le chiffre
d'affaires est inférieur à 1 million
d'euros c'est à dire une très grande
partie de nos entreprises le ministre
maire a récemment indiqué que le plan de
roy conquête et de transformation du
tourisme qui en cours d'élaboration
niveau national prendrait en compte des
spécificités des territoires d'outre-mer
je m'en réjouis mais de quelle façon
avec quels interlocuteurs trop souvent
ces plans sont rédigées cela plus large
concertation sans contact direct avec la
réalité
il nous faut des mesures adaptées à
chaque territoire le tourisme en
martinique n'est pas de la même nature
en guyane et à la réunion les acteurs
n'ont pas les mêmes stratégies ni les
mêmes besoins je demande une
concertation étroite avec les
professionnels de chaque territoire
d'outre-mer un changement de logique
qu'ils partiraient inévitablement du
terrain un plan de relance du tourisme
qui nous permettraient de des
investisseurs dont nous avons besoin de
rénover nos hôtels de montée en gamme de
diversifier notre offre touristique
monsieur le ministre
beaucoup dans nos entreprises du secteur
sont au bord du gouffre ne laissons pas
tomber
merci vous répondre monsieur
jean-baptiste lemoyne secrétaire d'état
chargé du tourisme des français de
l'étranger de la francophonie merci
beaucoup monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
madame la sénatrice le secteur du
tourisme outre-mer depuis le début
naturellement et en métropole aussi à
certaines périodes à était parti comme
un pacte et par les conséquences de la
crise sanitaire et d'ailleurs depuis le
début le présent dans le public a tenu
en faire une priorité nationale on en
est aujourd'hui à 37 milliards d'euros
qui ont été mis en place en soutien dans
le secteur du tourisme avec les
différentes mesures d'aidé de soutien
s'agissant de la martinique très
précisément nous avons pris avec
sébastien lecornu avec alain griset des
dispositions dès cet été dès que le pic
est intervenu pour pouvoir adapter les
dispositifs c'est vrai pour le fonds de
solidarité en force et c'est vrai pour
l'activité partielle qui reste avec ce
reste à charge 0 alors que le dispositif
ait voulu vous l'avez vu en métropole et
naturellement nous sommes attentifs à
tous les trous dans la raquette qui
pourrait être signalé nous avons 30 ont
d'ailleurs un dialogue avec les acteurs
du tourisme au sein du comité de filière
tourisme avec le président de la fedom
naturellement et nous veillerons à ce
que les outre mer et la martinique
singulièrement soit totalement partie
prenante de ce plan de reconquête
annoncé par le président de la
république c'était à saint cirq lapopie
et nous sommes déjà au stade d'être en
pratique avec mon collègue alain griset
nous avons d'ores et déjà
interrogé
les acteurs concernés par voie écrite
mais notre méthode a tous les deux c'est
le terrain et donc on a été aux côtés
des acteurs du tourisme littoral au mois
de juillet aux côtés des acteurs du
tourisme rural c'était il ya quelques
jours dans l'allier et nous aurons à
coeur lorsque la situation le permettra
naturellement d'aller à la rencontre des
acteurs du tourisme ultra manière 1 et
notamment antilles et pour pouvoir et
bien réfléchir avec eux aux meilleures
mesures pour rebondir voilà parce que
très clairement le tourisme ultramar est
une pépite pour l'économie locale et il
est une pépite aussi pour la destination
france donc soyez assurer de notre
entière détermination de ce point de vue
là
merci la parole maintenant monsieur
laurent saumon pour le groupe l'est
républicain
madame la ministre depuis 1980 le
constat est celui d'une france qui a
fait l'économie de sa culture
industrielle résultat une souveraineté
en berne dans nombre de domaines révélée
par la crise que l'aco vite 19 et un
capital humain en déperdition nos
talents nos étudiants sont ils condamnés
à s'expatrier que révèle l'exil des
forces vives de notre pays est ce que la
france fait le choix d'être la
championne du traversé deux frontières
pour sa recherche et son innovation
pourtant la france a de nombreux atouts
et c'est que la réussite de notre
réindustrialisation dépend de notre
capacité en recherche et innovation
madame la ministre vous formule donc
deux veut car votre ministère et la clé
de voûte de notre puissance économie
redonner l'appétit de la france aux
forces vives de notre pays agissait face
à l'immigration des natifs de france de
plus en plus jeunes placide animé
essentiel de la recherche et de
l'innovation en cette rentrée 2021
combien de nos bacheliers français
partent au canada en suisse en italie
aux etats-unis en espagne un seul
exemple concret l'école polytechnique de
lausanne comptait 41 % d'étudiants
français chiffre en hausse perpétuelle
de l'avis des spécialistes en économie
la réussite en économie la réussite des
filières françaises est jugée aléatoire
la formation peu épanouissante la peur
de se perdre est au rendez vous
conclusion le choix des formations
étrangères s'impose ne dites plus que
l'émigration des natifs de france est
une chance pour le rayonnement national
non c'est surtout le miroir de la
faiblesse de notre attractivité pour nos
jeunes talents en manque de
reconnaissance c'est une situation
schizophrène pour la recherche et pour
l'innovation
lesquels avec la formation notre
puissance économique ne survit pas avec
comme corollaire cette perte de
souveraineté madame la ministre le
manque de professeurs de sciences et de
mathématiques
le déclassement régulier de notre pays
dans l'évaluation pisa la fuite des
cerveaux les errements de parcours sur
l'insuffisance des besoins nos
n'anticipe et des master 2 et 1 alors
s'en suit un financement de la recherche
et de l'innovation trop timides sont
autant de constat du désintérêt pour les
filières d'excellence et du désamour de
notre enseignement supérieur qui manque
de moyens et d'attractivité madame la
ministre comment le gouvernement entend
prendre le virage du xxième siècle sans
communauté formée à la recherche et à
l'innovation et cela au delà du seul
plan de relance
merci répondre la parole et madame
frédéric vidal ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur sénateurs sont annoncés c'est
un concept j'aurais pu partager en 2012
quand j'étais présidente d'université ou
en 2017 quand j'étais aussi présidente
d'université mais loin du paysage
délabrée que vous êtes en train de
décrire moi je vais simplement vous
dirons nous en sommes aujourd'hui et où
nous en étions en 2017 en 2017 ça
faisait plus de vingt ans que les
financements de la recherche stagné en
2017 ont affecté les étudiants en tirant
au sort en 2017 en étaient invisibles
dans les classements internationaux ou
est-ce qu'on en est aujourd'hui et bien
aujourd'hui loin de ce que vous décrivez
la france et la troisième nation en
termes d'attractivité d'université de
recherche après les états unis et le
royaume uni sont qu'à première en europe
la france à la première université au
monde en mathématiques et il n'y a
jamais eu autant d'étudiants qui
demandait à venir étudier à paris saclay
que ces deux dernières années la france
est deuxième au monde en océanographie
elle est troisième au monde en écologie
donc il me semble monsieur sénateurs que
nous devons tous pouvoir nous en réjouir
et puis vous dites fuite des étudiants à
l'international là aussi un simple
chiffre alors sur la rentrée 2019-2020
puisque la crise qu vis de nous affecter
c'était 370 mille étudiants
internationaux s'étaient 23% de plus en
trois ans voilà c'est ça la réalité
aujourd'hui notre enseignement supérieur
et de notre recherche et comme je
suppose que vous avez applaudi dès
demain lors du vote de la loi pour la
recherche plus 25 milliards d'euros et
bien sachez que d'ores et déjà ses
chaire de professeur juniors dont
personne ne voulait bien il ya 180
demandes qui sont arrivés au ministère
sachez que d'ores et déjà la
revalorisation du dr à la revalorisation
de l'ensemble des professions de la
recherche les promotions tout ceci est
en train de fonctionner et je salue le
retour d'esther duflo parmi nous je
remercie
merci la parole est maintenant aux
présidents jean françois longeot pour le
groupe union centriste
monsieur le président madame alice mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
barbara pompiers mise la transition
écologique madame la ministre la loi de
finances pour 2021 prévu la révision à
la baisse du tarif d'achat de
l'électricité photovoltaïque
pour les contrats qui ont été conclus
entre 2006 et 2011 le sénat s'était
opposé à ce qu'il considérait comme une
remise en cause de la parole de l'état
le surcroît cette baisse envoie un
signal signifie qu est née gatif pour en
décourager les futurs investissements
dans le secteur si crucial des énergies
renouvelables
début juin les projets de textes
précisant les modalités de mise en
oeuvre ont conduit à le vu un levée de
boucliers des acteurs concernés pour ses
acteurs le barème de révision des tarifs
conduisent à une baisse à justifier
jusqu'à 90 % du tarif pour une baisse
moyenne de 55% soit un niveau jugé
insoutenable pour faire face aux
investissements qu'ils ont dû consentir
enfin la mesure ne prend pas assez en
compte la situation des exploitations
agricoles selon la fnsea les chambres
d'agriculture la mesure causerait la
faille de 500 producteurs du secteur
heureusement ce projet a été soumis à la
concertation une clause de sauvegarde
était définie pour éviter que la baisse
tarifaire ne conduise à des défauts de
paiement dès lors madame la ministre
frénétique des renégociations des
projets de textes d'application pouvez
vous nous en dire plus sur la clause de
sauvegarde par ailleurs si les économies
générées par une telle mesure sont
estimées à 500 millions d'euros par an
cette enveloppe budgétaire sera t-elle
fléchés vers le financement d'autres
projets renouvelables je vous remercie
merci pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame barbara pompili ministre de la
transition écologique merci monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
pessione sénateurs monsieur président
longeau que vous êtes là oui on doit
évidemment investir des moyens
considérables pour réussir la transition
écologique et oui le gouvernement engage
ses moyens pour développer les énergies
renouvelables et pour rattraper notre
retard en la matière et en témoignent
des 6 milliards d'euros que nous
déployons en 2021 mais nous ne devons
pas non plus sous couvert de transition
écologique nous satisfaire d'un certain
nombre de situations de rente qui
justement capte l'argent public et nous
empêche de mieux financer des projets
utiles en matière de transition
écologique et c'est pourquoi en effet la
dernière loi de finances initiale a
prévu de réviser certains gros contrats
de production qui date de 2006 à 2010
sur l'autoroute à ics afin de revenir à
une rémunération qui soit adaptée on
parle monsieur le président d'un millier
de contrats sur les 235 milles qui ont
été signés à cette époque et je l'avais
dit au moment de la loi de finances et
je vous le redis avec force aujourd'hui
ça ne doit pas conduire et ça ne
conduira pas à faire faire faillite à
une exploitation et je pense en
particulier vous l'avais dit aux
exploitants agricoles pour qui ces
installations viennent souvent apporter
un complément de revenu et la loi
prévoyait dès le départ monsieur le
président une clause de sauvegarde pour
traiter les situations individuelles
qu'ils nécessiteraient et j'y suis
particulièrement attentifs comme
l'ensemble gouvernement alors nous
allons prochainement adopter les textes
réglementaires permettant cette révision
et comme nous nous étions engagés vous
l'avez dit monsieur le président les
projets de textes ont fait l'objet d'une
large consultation des acteurs afin que
l'ensemble des textes réglementaires
puisse tenir compte de leurs
observations alors je vous le redis
monsieur le président non jo nous sommes
déterminés à revenir sur des situations
de rentes injustifiées qui coûte aux
contribuables
mais aucune des révisions ne menacera la
pérennité des installations concernées
et notre ambition en verre de
développement des énergies renouvelables
elle reste bien intact merci monsieur le
président lugo
oui merci j'ai bien entendu votre
message et on peut effectivement partagé
un certain nombre de choses dans votre
réponse mais quand même quand on veut
aujourd'hui incité un grand nombre de
nos concitoyens à entrer et à mettre en
place un certain nombre de moyens pour
des énergies renouvelables et que déjà
ils apprennent qu'on a remis en cause
des choses qui étaient prévus entre 2006
et 2011 ça n'incite pas effectivement à
à vouloir entrer dans ce système c'est
ça qui me gêne énormément merci merci la
parole est maintenant
à madame jacky de remédie pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la vaccination est disponible
en france et en outre-mer depuis huit
mois de nombreux français de l'étranger
n'ont pu voir leur famille depuis deux
ans les règles sanitaires locales les en
empêche car certains pays supprime les
visas de retour aux expatriés qui
quittent leur pays pour ceux qui ont
pris le risque de rentrer en france et
qui ont été vaccinés dans leur pays
d'accueil qu'ils étaient vaccinés avec
des vaccins homologués par l' agence
européenne du médicament ou avec des
vaccins non-homologuée leur vaccination
n'a pas été reconnue en france ils n'ont
eu d'autre choix que de subir des tests
la plupart du temps payant contrairement
à ce qui avait été annoncé à la fin de
l'été alors qu'ils sont repartis dans
leur pays d'accueil vous proposez que
ceux qui auraient été vaccinés avec des
vaccins listés par l' oms puisse
recevoir une troisième dose qui leur
permettrait de valider leurs vaccins
sept jours plus tard avez vous la
certitude que les vaccins reçus dans les
pays key quel vaccin que vous proposez
pour la troisième dose sont compatibles
de deux choses l'une soit les vaccins
utilisés non reconnu par l' oms et non
homologué par l'agencé européenne du
médicament sont inefficaces voire
dangereux et vous deviez interdire qu'il
soit inoculé à nos compatriotes et leur
fournir des vaccins agréés soit ce n'est
pas le cas et vous devez reconnaître
leur vaccination d'autre part dans un
certain nombre de pays dont l'iran
l'indonésie le vietnam la thaïlande la
birmanie est tellement d'autres un grand
nombre de français ne peuvent toujours
pas accéder à la vaccination
nos nombreuses interventions
n'aboutissent pas nos compatriotes ne
comprennent pas pourquoi des
dispositions urgentes ne sont pas prises
que répondez vous à nos élus qui sont en
première ligne
merci
réponse la parole est à monsieur jean
baptiste lemoyne secrétaire d'état
chargé du tourisme des français de
l'étranger la francophonie merci
beaucoup monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
madame la sénatrice jacky des comédies
la vaccination pour les français établis
hors de france mise en place par les
autorités françaises par ce gouvernement
je crois que on peut
non seulement se réjouir mais
s'enorgueillir parce que je crois que
nous sommes le seul pays au monde à nous
occuper non seulement de nos agents mais
des communautés de notes de nos
diasporas et c'est un motif de fierté je
pense partager avec jean yves le drian
avec le premier ministre que de savoir
que le ministère des affaires étrangères
a pu dans un premier temps justement
délivrer cette vaccination dans 45 états
45 pays qu aujourd'hui depuis que j'ai
pu rendre compte devant cette assemblée
le 12 juillet dernier eh bien deux du
déploiement de cette campagne elle s'est
poursuivie et s'est poursuivie avec
l'appui de la société internationale
souhaite que vous connaissez bien et
depuis le 12 juillet dernier nous avons
continué à envoyer ses vaccins je le
cite au burundi au vietnam en russie au
gabon au rwanda en tunisie en argentine
à l'île maurice au mali au turkménistan
aux comores au venezuela je pourrais
continuer c'est vous dire que nous
continuons à être au plus près de nos
communautés pour pouvoir leur fournir ce
service si précieux et s'agissant de nos
compatriotes qui ont été vaccinées dans
les systèmes locaux auparavant je veux
dire que là aussi beaucoup d'énergie
étaient déployés pour que nous puissions
délivrer les qr codes et les passes
sanitaires pour les français de
l'étranger qui était vacciné avec les
vaccins homologués c'est vrai et
aujourd'hui nous en sommes à cent mille
pas sanitaire des livres et c'était le
chiffre à hier je crois qu'on peut en
être légitimement fiers et nous avons
ouvert une nouvelle voie effectivement
pour les vacciner avec des vaccins qui
ne sont pas homologués mais qui sont sur
la liste de l'om s et sur proposition du
directeur général de la santé le conseil
de défense effectivement a ouvert cette
voie qui doit être confirmée dans les
tout prochains jours par la prise
comment dire par un décret qui va être
pris par le ministère de la santé lui
même ayant pris la tâche de la has pour
que tout se déroule dans les meilleures
conditions donc voilà nous sommes à la
tâche loin des leçons de morale sur le
sujet auprès de leurs compatriotes
merci madame d'euromédis pour la grippe
h1n1 en 2009 les français de l'étranger
avait pu compter sur la solidarité
nationale et tous ceux qui le
souhaitaient avaient été vaccinés ou
qu'ils soient nos compatriotes résidant
à l'étranger ont droit à la protection
sanitaire de la france
merci la parole est maintenant à madame
hélène conway mouret pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
merci monsieur le président sur le
secrétaire d'état mes chers collègues un
an c'est le temps dont vous disposiez
pour organiser dans les meilleures
conditions d'élection des six sénateurs
représentant les français établis hors
de france neuf jours c'est le temps qui
reste avant le vote par anticipation le
18 septembre et 17 jours pour le vote à
l'urne à paris or certains grands
électeurs en raison des restrictions de
déplacement en vigueur dans leur pays
notamment en australie et en nouvelle
zélande ne savent toujours pas si quand
et comment ils seront en mesure de voter
pour les élections sénatoriales auront
même que ce vote est obligatoire toutes
les demandes de clarification voire de
dérogation sollicité par les passes et
les élus depuis des semaines sont
restées lettre morte mais cela semble
être votre mode de gouvernance resté
sourd aux alertes et attendre la
dernière minute pour réagir pour preuve
ce n'est que ce matin lors d'une réunion
convoquée en urgence que vous avez
consulté les parlementaires sur la tenue
des élections partielles pour dix
conseillers des français de l'étranger
qui n'ont pas pu se tenir en mai dernier
dans trois circonscriptions
n'auriez pu d'ailleurs prévoir la
prolongation de leur mandat comme nous
le proposions depuis février dernier
afin que les conseils consulaires puisse
se tenir notamment les conseils de
bourse et les cpas et que les
conseillers ne soit pas ignoré par
l'administration plutôt que d'improviser
en catastrophe un amendement d'ailleurs
très largement améliorées par le sénat
mais le texte a été promulgué trop tard
il y a trois jours vous nous informés
par courrier que le vote par internet ne
serait pas possible alors même que les
électeurs ont voté six fois plus par
internet qu'à l'une au dernier scrutin
l'encore si vous aviez tirer les leçons
du passé vous auriez anticipé la
prorogation du contrat du prestataire
jusqu'à la fin 2021 deux mois c'est donc
le temps qu'il vous reste pour organiser
ces élections partielles et celle des
conseillers à l'assemblée des français
de l'étranger et pour l'instant rien
n'est prévu pour le renouvellement des
membres afee au conseil d'administration
de la caisse des français de l'étranger
monsieur sont interdites à ma question
est simple votre réponse est désormais
urgente quelles instructions allez vous
ou avez vous envoyé au poste pour que
les grands électeurs en australie et en
nouvelle-zélande puissent voter dans
quelques jours merci pour répondre la
parole est à monsieur jean baptiste
lemoyne secrétaire d'état chargé du
tourisme des français de l'étranger la
francophonie merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices madame la ministre un sur le
l'élection sénatoriale les choses se
préparent en bon ordre dans le calme en
toute sérénité et là aussi en nous
attachant à ce que chacun des grands
électeurs puissent exprimer son vote
vous évoquez la situation en australie
en nouvelle zélande en nous parce que
dans ces pays un certain nombre de
règles limitant la mobilité en raison de
confinement sont prises et bien
justement c'est le rôle de la diplomatie
française que de s'assurer auprès de ses
pays de résidences que nos compatriotes
grands électeurs pourront se déplacer
c'est le cas en australie cet acquis
nous sommes en bonne voie en
nouvelle-zélande mais comprenez que je
ne peux pas moi-même répondre à la place
des autorités des pays de résidence ça
s'appelle la souveraineté c'est un
concept assez basique s'agissant des
élections consulaires c'est le parlement
qui a disposé pour repousser
effectivement dans un premier temps d'un
an le scrutin là aussi je crois que nous
pouvons gagner avec jean yves le drian
d'un fait en sorte que dans 127 des 130
circonscriptions le scrutin ait pu se
tenir au moment où le pic
pis des milk était présent dans de
nombreux pays du monde hélas dans trois
circonscriptions en inde et à madagascar
et on se souvient tous des images
frappantes de l'inde et nous avons été
en soutient d'ailleurs de ce pays il n'a
pas pu se tenir et le parlement a
délibéré les élections seront donc
organisées d'ici la fin de l'année et
nous faisons face tout simplement un
certain nombre de contraintes liées aux
marchés publics qui font que ce vote par
internet effectivement ne peut pas se
tenir dans ce que temps là il faut
passer un marché public il faut que la
solution soit mise en oeuvre et donc
nous avons pris le temps d'examiner
toutes les solutions à la grande
différence de ce que vous avez fait avec
ans lorsque vous étiez soit au
gouvernement soit soutien du précédent
gouvernement en 2015 lorsque au paraguay
vous avez écarté d'un revers de la main
le vote par internet au motif du coup
nous le coup on assume on est prêt à
l'assumer mais à un moment il a le droit
il ya la règle est donc on s'y plie et
bien sachez que les élections partielles
pourront être organisés autour du 7
novembre ainsi l' effet pour être
renouvelée autour du 5 décembre et
l'assemblée des français de l'étranger
pourra se réunir là aussi en toute
sérénité en bon ordre dans le calme et
nous serons en marche pour travailler
avec elle en décembre eh bien
la parole est maintenant monsieur jean
baptiste blanc pour le groupe l'est
républicain
sur le président mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au ministre chargé
des affaires européennes monsieur le
ministre les producteurs de lavande et
de lavandin sont extrêmement inquiets au
regard du projet de révision du
règlement reach sur la stratégie de la
chimie durable qui serait proposée par
la commission entre 2022 2023 et qui
propose un certain nombre de mesures
difficilement tenable pour la filière
des huiles essentielles le risque quel
est il il est de voir qu la cellule
essentielle de lavande au du naturel aux
nombreuses vertus dans la liste des
produits dangereux ce produit n'est pas
dangereux mon collègue bruno belin par
ailleurs pharmaciens pourraient vous le
confirmer
sur le site officiel en tout cas c'est
une véritable menace pour l'ensemble de
la filière l'avant dit cole mais
également par ricochet celle du tourisme
c'est cette culture couvre plus de 4000
hectares produit annuellement 84 tonnes
d'huiles essentielles dont 19 tonnes
d'huile essentielle de lavande d'autres
au vent ça hop et cela génère 9000
emplois directs et 17 mille emplois
indirects liés à l'activité touristique
monsieur le ministre l'huile essentielle
de lavande et d'un produit issu de notre
agriculture française elle doit le
rester nous demandons deux choses
d'abord que soient réunis au plus tôt le
comité de suivi de la réglementation
reach et comptons sur votre mobilisation
pleine et entière auprès de la
commission européenne afin d'exiger une
approche spécifique adapté aux produits
naturels et aux huiles essentielles
pourtant garanti sans bien sûr la
sécurité du consommateur et de
l'environnement ensuite nous demandons
un soutien franc et massif des cinq
ministères car il y en a cinq
l'agriculture la transition écologique
la santé le travail l'économie monsieur
le ministre coordonnées de grâce ces
ministères parce que pendant ce temps là
l'europe à des projets que nous ne
voulons pas monsieur le ministre ce
produit là n'est pas dangereux
et pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur clément bonne secrétaire d'état
chargé des affaires européennes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jean baptiste blanc je vous
prie tout d'abord de bien vouloir
excuser l'absence cet après-midi du
ministre l'agriculture de l'alimentation
et je viens de normandie qui est retenu
aujourd'hui dans le loiret pour le salon
innov-agri qui nécessitait sa présence
mais il a réuni vous le savez ce matin
d'ores et déjà l'ensemble des acteurs de
la filière et la préoccupation que vous
avez relayé celle de l'ensemble des
producteurs de lavande l'agout le
gouvernement la partagent l'ensemble des
ministères concernés que vous avez
d'ailleurs cité de quoi s'agit-il il
s'agit de la révision d'une
réglementation européenne
le règlement dit rich qui recense évalue
et le cas échéant permet de contrôler un
certain nombre de substances chimiques
extrêmement variés je rappelle
d'ailleurs que la filière des huiles
essentielles et déjà concernés par
l'application du règlement reach la
commission européenne a fait état d'un
projet de révision de ce règlement reach
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas de
calendrier précis nous n'avons pas non
plus le contenu de cette révision il
s'agit donc d'une alerte que nous devons
entendre et nous mobiliser dès
maintenant je veux préciser que nous
ferons tout ce travail en lien avec
l'ensemble des professionnels c'était le
sens de la première réunion organisée
par julien de normandie ce matin il a
annoncé à l'ensemble des professionnels
la mise en place d'un comité
interministériel d'information et de
suivi qui associera précisément les
administrations des cinq ministères
concernés que vous avez cités l'ensemble
des représentants de la filière pour que
le projet soit connue identifié dès sa
présentation concrète ce qui n'est pas
encore le cas par la commission
européenne que le cas échéant s'il y
avait des inquiétudes sur son contenu la
france puisse porter en définition cette
position commune relayer ses inquiétudes
ses préoccupations et faire évoluer ce
projet je rappelle que quoi qu'il arrive
le simple effet d'annonce qui crée cette
préoccupation légitime de la commission
européenne nous n'avons pas encore de
texte en discussion et que ce ne sera
pas avant la fin de l'année 2022 qu'une
éventuelle réglementation modifié
s'appliquerait nous avons du temps mais
nous devons prendre cette alerte au
sérieux et suivre ensemble les mesures
apportées les inquiétudes à relayer il
faut tirer pour nous le ferons le
ministre de l'agriculture de
l'alimentation s'y est engagée
publiquement très clairement ce matin
merci la parole est à monsieur blanc
non merci et bien la parole est donc à
madame jocelyne guide aise pour le
groupe union centriste
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madère
la mini semaine l oag on est elle porte
sur la situation désastreuse que
connaissent ces salariés et les
allocataires dans les caf suite à la
mise en place de la réforme de
l'allocation logement en effet cette
réforme continue de générer de
nombreuses difficultés dans les cafés
qui s'ajoutent à une situation déjà
fortement dégradées depuis plusieurs
années
cela impacte directement l'ensemble des
salariés et par voie de conséquence les
allocataires les difficultés et
dysfonctionnements informatiques
s'enchaînent perturbant ainsi le
traitement des prestations familiales et
les minima sociaux ainsi les retards
s'accumulent avec un pic à près de 5
millions de pièces en attente les délais
de mise en paiement de l'ensemble des
prestations des allocataires sont
fortement allongée et convient de
rappeler que ces dernières représentent
pour leurs bénéficiaires une partie
importante de leurs ressources
mensuelles
cette situation n'est pas acceptable
il est urgent que des solution pérenne
soit trouvée particulièrement en cette
période de crise sanitaire et économique
quelles mesures immédiates vont être
déployés par le gouvernement pour
résoudre ce problème compte tenu de la
gravité de l'urgence de la situation
que comptez vous faire madame la
ministre pour aider les salariés et les
allocataires qui sont aujourd'hui en
grande difficulté nous espérons une
réponse engagé douvres merci merci
pouvoir répondre la parole est à mme
adam emmanuel var ministre délégué
auprès de la ministre de la transition
écologique chargé du logement
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice jocelyne guide s vous l'avez
signalé la réforme des appels a été mise
en place conformément aux engagements
que nous avons pris au 1er janvier
dernier cette réforme est une réforme
qui ne changent pas le mode de calcul
des droits mais qui permet de le
calculer sur les ressources récentes les
plus connus et qui nécessitait un
changement de système d'information
cette réforme a été tout de suite
pleinement opérationnel et je voudrais
saluer et remercier les agents des caf
qui ont fait face à ce changement de
système toujours forcément un petit peu
difficile avec beaucoup d'engagement
professionnel et beaucoup de motivation
nous avons constaté quelques bugs et
anomalie informatique ce qui est souvent
le cas quand on change d'un système de
gestion de systèmes d'information qui
concerne six millions d'allocataires ces
bugs ont pu concerner jusqu'à 2 à 3 %
des dossiers et sont en voie de
résorption puisque nous sommes
maintenant plutôt autour de 1 % des
dossiers vous savez maintenant les
appels sont recalculés chaque trimestre
les calculs ont eu lieu en avril puis
cet été de façon satisfaisante les
correctifs informatiques sont en voie
d'être apportées et toute l'équipe de
direction de la cnav sous le contrôle
des partenaires sociaux de son conseil
d'administration sont pleinement
mobilisés à la fois pour soutenir les
agents et pour continuer les évolutions
techniques du système d'information qui
sont nécessaires avec olivier ferrand et
avec olivier dussopt pts nous suivons
cette situation avec beaucoup
d'attention l'évolution des systèmes
d'informations de la cnaf continuera
elle est nécessaire également pour
continuer à rapprocher les prestations
puisque avoir la même base ressources
pour toutes les prestations de la cnaf
c'est aussi l'assurance de pouvoir avoir
des télédéclarations qui ne nécessitent
plus d'aller re déclarer ses ressources
et ses droits à chaque actualisation
c'est aussi la possibilité de rapprocher
demain les prestations et d'aller vers
un revenu universel d'activité qui fait
toujours partie de nos projets merci
madame 10 days
oui je peux pas dire que la réponse
satisfasse ce complètement parce que
face à cette crise sans précédent qui
place justement la branche famille au
bord du précipice une action rapide
concrètes et profondes et des mesures
fortes de la part de l'état en tous les
cas sont attendus je pense quand même
que les soucis continuent puisque on est
venu vers moi pour comble pour me le
dire plusieurs prestataires en tous les
cas sont en difficulté aujourd'hui donc
j'espère en effet que ça va se régler
rapidement merci à vous merci dernière
question monsieur jean louis masson pour
la réunion administrative des sénateurs
ne figurant sur la liste d'aucun groupe
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre
la fonction publique était jusqu'à
présent logique de méritocratie chacun
pouvant se présenter à des examens et
concours la réussite dépendants de la
valeur personnelle de chacun
le système n'était pas parfait mais mais
ils étaient au moins justes or sous
couvert d'une fausse égalité des chances
on veut remplacer c'est à dire le
gouvernement veut remplacer ce
fonctionnement par une logique de
nominations au jour le jour sur des
appréciations qui seront totalement
subjective et arbitraire il y à là à mon
avis un vrai danger d'injustice on le
voit d'ailleurs déjà actuellement
lorsqu'il s'agit de nommer certains
préfets dans des fonctions qui n'ont
rien à voir avec la mission présente
préfectoral le certains ambassadeurs
que ce soit aux tons loup à l'équateur
dont on se demande comment il se
retrouve ambassadeurs on le voit au tour
extérieur de manière plus générale pour
les gens qui sont nommés au tour
extérieur par exemple au conseil d'état
ou à la cour des comptes
ces gens là sont ils toujours nommés
parce qu'ils ont parce qu'ils sont les
plus compétents où sont-ils nommé parce
qu'ils ont des relations les évolutions
de carrière monsieur le premier ministre
ne doivent pas
s'exercer se réaliser de cette façon est
la question que je voudrais vous poser
le processus le profil de carrière doit
dépendre de la valeur des personnes et
avec le système que vous allez mettre en
place ce qu'ils vont réussir c'est sûr
ce sont ceux qui auront des relations
familiales ceux qui font partie de
réseaux occultes tels que la franc
maçonnerie ou ceux qui ont un piston
politique alors monsieur le premier
ministre
ne croyez vous pas que votre réforme qui
veut qu'ils essayent de faire croire à
tous les français qu'on va leur donner
des chances et bien c'est quelque chose
c'est une véritable n'est pas une
véritable tromperie parce que faire
croire à quelqu'un qui est dans une
subtile n'a aucune formation
va être dit va trouver au conseil d'état
ou ailleurs c'est se moquer du monde
merci chers collègues la parole pour
répondre et à madame amélie de
montchalin minnis de la transformation
et de la fonction publique
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur en république il y à un
principe
c'est celui de l'article 6 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen qui dit que l'emploi public est
égale pour tous dans son accès en tenant
compte des mérites et des talons
mini de la fonction depuis que je suis
devant vous aujourd'hui je ne saurait
laisser passer l'idée que
à coups de complotisme de fake news vous
mettriez ici en doute d'abord la
compétence l'engagement et le service de
l'intérêt général qui est au coeur du
quotidien de ses cadres de l'état de ces
hauts fonctionnaires qui aujourd'hui
font tenir le pays ils le font tenir
depuis 1945 suite à une ordonnance que
vous savez que le général de gaulle
avait préparé avec michel debré et qui
consiste à reconstruire la france dans
un monde où nous avions besoin des
meilleurs sur tous les sujets nous
sommes aujourd'hui en 2021 depuis 1945
il s'est passé des choses la
décentralisation en 82 il vient de se
passer une crise sanitaire les jeunes
aujourd'hui ne voit plus la fonction
publique nécessairement comme un lieu
attractif alors oui sous l'autorité du
président la république du premier
ministre nous avons posé trois principes
1 l'état doit connaître ses besoins au
plus près des territoires pour être
efficace et apporter des solutions la
wii français vivent c'est donc le
réarmement l'état territorial 2 nous
croyons aux compétences plus qu'au corps
nous voulons mettre en avant les métiers
et c'est bien par les compétences par
leur évaluation par la connaissance de
l'état de qui sont les hommes et les
femmes qui le servent que nous voulons
et bien organisés les parcours les
carrières 3 nous croyons que les
personnes font souvent plus
talentueusement un métier qu'ils ont
choisi et que nous vous devons mettre au
coeur de la fonction publique l'écouté
des aspirations des uns et des autres
nous croyons la république nous croyons
en la démocratie je ne laisserai pas
penser que sous couvert d'une question
polémique vous viendrez ici remettre en
cause l'engagement des hauts
fonctionnaires mais ils attendent que
nous ferions mieux leur carrière leur
engagement leur rémunération leur
liberté et que nous soyons capables de
mettre en face de chaque problème dans
chaque territoire la personne aux bonnes
compétences j'aurai l'occasion et jamais
éléphants devant vous autant que de
besoin mais cette réforme est
essentielle à l'efficacité leurs actions
publiques
merci je vous rappelle que les
prochaines questions d'actualité auront
lieu le mercredi 22 septembre
je constate que le sénat ait puisé son
ordre du jour pour la deuxième session
extraordinaire
le président du sénat a reçu de monsieur
le président la république
communication du décret portant clôture
de la session extraordinaire
en conséquence il est priac de la
clôture de la session cette information
sera publiée au journal officiel et sur
le site internet de notre assemblée
monsieur le président du sénat ya reçu
communication du décret portant
convocation du parlement en session
extraordinaire à compter du lundi 20
septembre
la prochaine séance aura lieu le mardi
21 septembre à 14h30 pour la proposition
de loi permettant la réélection des
juges consulaires dans les tribunaux de
commerce la séance est levée
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement que vous
avez pu suivre en intégralité sur public
sénat il a été question de la réforme
des retraites qui pour l'instant elle
n'est pas poursuivie par le gouvernement
également de l'urgence sanitaire en
outre-mer alors que ce matin le sénat a
voté en faveur de la prorogation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire dans les
territoires ultramarins et puis il a
également été question de précarité de
pouvoir d'achat avec le premier ministre
jean castex qui a évoqué bien une hausse
automatique du smic pour la fin d'année
et puis les sénateurs ont également
parlé
de la précarité étudiante c'est un sujet
qui est très important pour le sénat et
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
frédéric vidal a défendu le bilan du
gouvernement pour soutenir les étudiants
précarité on va voir tous ces moments
forts de ces questions d'actualité au
gouvernement avec quentin calmet qui est
en tribune de presse de l'hémicycle du
sénat qu en tant qu est ce que vous avez
retenu dans les moments forts de cette
séance vous avez déjà pas mal résumé
cette séance alex mais on va revenir
cette question du pouvoir d'achat
c'était la toute première question
aujourd'hui on sait avec la hausse des
prix et des carburants également des
tarifs réglementés du gaz il ya cette
inquiétude autour du pouvoir d'achat des
français et donc les sénateurs
communistes se soit interrogé sur une
possible hausse des salaires avec
notamment un coup de pouce au smic vous
l'avez dit alex ou également et bien du
point d'indicé pour les fonctionnaires
écoutez la réponse du premier ministre
nous n'excluons pas effectivement qu'il
y ait une revalorisation automatique du
smic nous verrons bien
compte tenu de l'évolution des prix
avant le 1er janvier prochain il n'est
pas question je vous le dis madame
d'augmenter le point d'indicé
il ya pas plus injuste en revanche vous
verrez dans le projet de loi de finances
pour 2022 dont vous aurez à débattre
prochainement que nous faisons des
actions pour les agents de catégorie c
et que dire de l'impact pouvoir d'achat
des mesures du ségur la santé qui vont
également se déployer cette fois ci dans
le cadre du plfss pour 2022 autre moment
fort sur lequel je voulais revenir c'est
sur la question effectivement de la
réforme des retraites la droite à poser
des questions notamment avec rené paul
savary qui est dit en début de questions
si j'ai bien compris vous avait abdiqué
sur cette réforme des retraites et donc
c'est l'europe les trajets ski le
secrétaire d'état en charge cette
réforme qui lui a répondu il y est dit
cette réforme étant dispo indispensable
il faudra à la ferme à leur camp écoutez
là encore la réponse du ministre alors
nous le réaliserons quand nous le
réaliserons lorsque la situation
sanitaire sera revenu à la normale et
l'or que la croissance économique sera
définitivement ancré ne vous a pas
échappé qu'il n'y a plus de 2200 de nos
concitoyens qui sont encore en
réanimation aujourd'hui et que la
priorité de ce gouvernement aujourd'hui
c'est d'ancrer la relance il d'assurer
la protection de la santé de nos
concitoyens est donc en réplique on a
entendu l'ironie dlr qui ont pu dire
ensuite quand on ne veut pas réformer on
trouve toujours de bons prétextes pour
ne pas le faire alex merci beaucoup
quand on va maintenant recueillir les
réactions des ministres et des sénateurs
à la sortie de l'hémicycle du sénat et
on va parler d'europe puisque steve
jourdain et en selle les conférences
avec clément bonne le secrétaire d'état
chargé des affaires européennes oui
clément bonne bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous vous préparer pour
le mois de janvier janvier la france
prend la présidence de l'union
européenne en amont et bien vous vous
préparez à cette présidence vous lancé
ce week-end une grande consultation sur
l'europe expliquez nous en quoi ça
consiste
alors relancer effectivement l'exercice
qui est totalement inédit puisque dans
toutes les régions de france de
métropole et d'outre-mer nous allons sur
deux week-ends du mois de septembre ça
commence demain et ça se poursuivra
jusqu'à la fin du mois
des panels citoyens de citoyens tirés au
sort 50 par région qui sont
représentatifs de la diversité des
catégories socio professionnelles qui
sont les groupes évidemment paritaire
qui vont discuter librement pendant
trois jours deux propositions de
critiques de volonté de réforme pour
dire quels changements il voudrait pour
l'europe et ses propositions là nous en
ferons la synthèse nationale de manière
transparente d'ici à la fin du mois
d'octobre et cela viendra alimenter cet
agenda que nous portons pour la
présidence française de l'union
européenne qui commence dans quelques
semaines et qui peut participer à ces
débats se sont pour la première fois des
citoyens qui ont été tirés au sort pour
avoir justement un panel représentatif
pour ne pas avoir ce qui participe
toujours à ces débats sur l'europe ou
ceux qui considèrent que l'europe
forcément est la cause de tous les maux
nous aurons un panel de toutes les
opinions publiques des ministres estime
pauline ces débats il n'y aura pas de
vent laissait récemment politique au
sens où personne ne viendra perturber le
déroulement des débats ce doit être les
propositions des citoyens mais il y aura
dans les régions qui les concerne le
plus quelques ministres qui viendront en
ouverture ou en clôture d'hier nous
prendrons ces propositions au sérieux
elle nourriront la présidence française
quelles sont les thématiques quelles
sont les questions qui seront posées aux
citoyens c'est une question très large
que nous avons voulu justement la plus
ouverte possible
quels changements voulez vous pour
l'europe en tant que citoyens français
nous ne préjugeons pas des thèmes ou des
propositions que voudront faire les
citoyennes et citoyens français qui
participent à ces débats et quand le
tirage au sort a été effectué et que
beaucoup de citoyens ont été contactés
il ya eu un très fort intérêt qui a été
exprimée pour cet exercice clément donne
cette grande consultation c'est aussi
une manière de préparer le programme
présidentiel d'emmanuel macro non pas du
tout je crois que sur l'europe on ne
cherche pas des idées ailleurs en
quelque sorte la mesure où emmanuel
macron s'est engagé de longue date sur
l'europe bien sûr cela éclairera ses
consultations tous ceux qui le veulent à
un camp ou un autre un parti ou un autre
une personne ou une autre ses rapports
avec les propositions des citoyens
seront publiques chacun pourra en tirer
des idées ou des conséquences clément
bonne on a aussi appris aujourd'hui la
convocation pour demain inde agnès buzyn
devant la cour de justice de la
république quelle est votre réaction
aucune car il s'agit je le comprends
d'une procédure judiciaire qui suit son
cours et je m'astreins ne faire aucun
commentaire sur les procédés tête sur la
forme la cour de justice de la
république qu'est ce que vous en pensez
rien en l'occurrence parce que ce n'est
pas à m'immiscer si la procédure a été
suivie au titre des fonctions d'une
ancienne ministre c'est à la justice
quelle que soit la juridiction de suivre
son cours merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup civ et maintenant place
aux débrief de ces questions d'actualité
avec mes invités cet après-midi
j'accueille d'abord sur ce plateau
pierre ouzoulias sénateurs communistes
des hauts-de-seine bonjour jour olivier
paccaud vous êtes sénateur attaché au
groupe l'est républicain du sénat et
vous êtes sénateur de l'oise bonjour
bonjour et puis j accueille également
jean yves le conte sénateurs socialistes
des français établis hors de france on
va d'abord réagir sur et bien
le cas à nice busan puisque agnès buzyn
est convoqué par la cour de justice de
la république pour sa gestion de la
crise sanitaire jean yves le conte est
ce que vous trouvez normal que
l'ancienne miss de la santé soient mises
en cause dans sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire
je pense qu'il ya rien à dire à ce stade
il ya une procédure qui a été suivi
comme le disait clément bonne voie la
cca la cour de justice de la république
doit se prononcer et pourtant les
sénateurs ont beaucoup travaillé dans
leur commission d' enquête sur la
gestion de la crise sanitaire notamment
sur les stocks de masques les sénateurs
ont montré que l'état avait failli dans
et bien la constitution de stocks de
masques préventif en cas d'épidémie
olivier paccaud est-ce que vu que l'état
a failli sur ce point est ce qu'il faut
que les ministres soient condamnés
condamné je ne pense pas c'est
préoccupant parce que s'il a réellement
condamnation nous allons avoir une
paralysie de l'action gouvernementale on
voudra plus rien faire on n'osera plus
rien dire ou prendre certaines décisions
qui pourraient susciter ensuite des
condamnations alors la meilleure le
meilleur des jugements ce sera celui des
électeurs après quand il ya des
responsabilités dans des faits graves
bon je veux bien mais je suis quand même
assez perturbé je vais prendre un
exemple précis
si madame busin est
condamné à je ne sais quoi le premier
ministre qui avait parlé de masques
france-klm en propre et de lecteurs
que va-t-il lui arriver
ça pose un vrai problème il ya
certainement eu des erreurs dans la
gestion de la crise c'est clair et net
et il est masqué malheureusement c'est
peut-être la plus grosse erreur mais ce
gouvernement a tenté de faire face le
parlement a tenté de jouer son action en
corrigeant alors aujourd'hui c'est à la
justice de faire son travail néanmoins
nous sommes dans un équilibre très
compliqué très délicat un l'état de
droit a c'est effectivement la
séparation des pouvoirs et chacun doit
jouer son rôle néanmoins il ne faudrait
pas devenir un état où le judiciaire
prenne le pas sur le politique est
résolue à ce que vous pensez que la
justice va paralyser l'action de l'état
avec ces procédures sur la gestion de la
crise sanitaire moi je pense qu'il faut
remettre cette question
après le séisme électoral conte avec eux
et la grève des urnes il ya quand même
70 % de nos compatriotes qui se sont pas
déplacés pour voter et ils ont signifié
en cela une forme de défiance vis-à-vis
du gouvernement des institutions
moi je pense que si le gouvernement dans
la gestion de la crise avait été plus
transparent notamment vis-à-vis du
parlement serait permis un portage
politique générale des mesures
sanitaires qui ont été décidées ce que
le gouvernement a pas fait il ya
systématiquement gérer tout seul dans
son coin en donnant des informations
maintenant il faut la transparence mais
on va aller voir l'un des sénateurs qui
était à la tête de la commission d'
enquête du sénat sur la gestion de la
crise sanitaire bernard jomier sénateur
socialiste de paris qui est en salle des
conférences avec style jourdain ouï
bernard jomier vous êtes en quelque
sorte que monsieur qu'ovide du sénat
bonjour merci d'être avec nous on a donc
appris la convocation d'agnès busin
demain devant la cour de justice de la
république elle risque une mise en
examen pour sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire quelle est votre première
réaction à notre micro
le premier point ce qu' il est tout à
fait normal qu'un responsable politique
assume ses actes jusqu'au bout non dans
toutes ses dimensions après moi je ne
suis pas favorable à la procédure de
cour de justice de la république je
considère que les responsables
politiques devraient être soumis à un
régime de droit commun devant la justice
comme tous les autres mais le dispositif
est là qui s'imposent à nous ce que je
constate d'abord c inq la commission
denquête nous n'avions pas relever de
faute personnelle particulière
agnès buzyn de madame buses à nous en
avions relevé du directeur général de la
santé par exemple par contre mais pas
d'agnès busin mais deuxièmement et je
pense ce point est assez important c'est
que nous avons
je mens souligné le fait que le mode de
prise décision de l'exécutif dans cette
crise était beaucoup trop sucrés manqué
beaucoup trop de transparence avec le
conseil de défense sanitaire et donc je
vous comprends que les enquêteurs de la
cjr et du mal je ça de prendre et besoin
de convoquer en tout cas agnès buzyn
pour l'entendre je ne sais pas quelle
sera la suite je ne sais pas si elle
sera mise en examen évidemment mais je
comprends qu'ils aient besoin de la
convoquer pour comprendre et pour qu'il
y ait un minimum de transparence et
d'explications sur les décisions prises
selon vous sur les éléments dont vous
disposiez dont vous disposez agnès buzyn
n'est pas en cause dans cette gestion de
la crise sanitaire je veux c'est qu'on
prenne nous avons eu beaucoup de mal à
mettre à jour les faits et que après
l'avoir entendu au mois de janvier très
longuement devant la commission denquête
et après en avoir délibéré entre nous et
au vu des pièces écrites qui ont été
portés à notre connaissance nous n'avons
pas pour notre part relevé de faute
judiciaire j'allais dire après le
jugement politique ce sont les électeurs
qui doivent sanctionner évidemment et
pas la justice dans leur jeu mais petit
petit mot sur cette rentrée politique ce
soit rentrée parlementaire pitel sur le
front sanitaires les chiffres qui
continuent de baisser est ce que le plus
dur est passé selon vous alors le plus
dur oui j'espère parce que maintenant il
ya deux grandes hypothèses la première
qui serait très drôle dommageable se
serait l'émergence de nouveaux variants
qui lui président présenterait une
résistance au vaccin et qui en quelque
sorte remettrait les compteurs un peu à
0,2 hormis cette hypothèse en combe
appelé noir l'espace du virus se réduit
et on l'a vu la quatrième banque qui
nous a touché cet été en métropole n'a
pas provoqué de saturation des hôpitaux
mais elle a provoqué de nouveaux cas on
n'en n'a pas fini il faut réduire encore
plus fortement la circulation du virus
en métropole et dans les territoires
ultramarins cet autre chose et nous
allons travailler particulièrement sur
cette question là il ya des risques
élevés le qui persistent merci beaucoup
merci bernard jeu mais avoir répondu à
mes questions
si beaucoup si on va parler d'un autre
aspect de cette crise sanitaire c'est la
précarité étudiante nos jeunes ont été
frappés par les conséquences de cette
crise du coronavirus et ça a été l'un
des sujets des échanges durant cette
séance de questions d'actualité la
sénatrice écologiste monique de marco
qui a interrogé la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur frédéric vidal
sur cette précarité étudiante on écoute
les changes
l'enquète annuel publié par l'unef
évalue la hausse du coût de la vie
étudiante à plus de 2 5% par rapport à
l'an dernier et à plus de 10% par
rapport au début du quinquennat
en même temps les aides directes ont
baissé de 39 euros en moyenne par
étudiant et par an alors qu'ils avaient
augmenté lors du mandat précédent
évidemment le gouvernement à accompagner
et va continuer à accompagner les
étudiants 3,3 milliards d'euros dans le
budget 2001 2 pour la vie étudiante ça
n'avait jamais atteint ce niveau pierre
aux audiences vous avez présidé la
mission d'information du sénat sur la
précarité étudiante et encore c'est un
sujet important pour le sénat qu'est ce
que vous avez pensé des propos de la
ministre d'après midi qui finalement
défend le bilan du gouvernement en
disant voilà on a mis les moyens on a
aidé les jeunes mais comme on dit dans
les campus tout baigne c'est ce que
pense la ministre moi j'ai fait la
tournée des campus
les enseignants chercheurs les étudiants
ils voient pas de différence par rapport
à l'année à l'année dernière et la
ministre a fait un aveu que personne a
relevé à propos de la prolongation de la
mesure pour le repas
un euro elle a dit que bien évidemment
les boursiers continuerons à en profiter
mais aussi les précaires non boursiers
et donc on apprend que nous avons en
france un système de bourses qui laisse
une part non-négligeable d'étudiants sur
le bord du chemin qu'ils soient en
grande précarité donc la seule mesure
importante qu'on attendait de la
ministre c'est une réforme des bourses
pour faire qu'il n'y ait plus de
précarité étudiante et ça c'était
possible il ya eu des débuts des
annonces présidentielles est là depuis
la rentrée il n'y a absolument plus rien
olivier paccaud qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette politique du
gouvernement de soutien aux jeunes elle
a longtemps été la critique et est ce
que l exécutif s'est rattrapé sur ce
point je suis comme pierre aux liasses
membres de la commission culture et
c'est des sujets qui nous tiennent à
coeur alors le gouvernement a beaucoup
parlé il a - j néanmoins je pense que
c'est un sujet qui doit être majeur pour
les prochains mois et pour la campagne
présidentielle qui s'ouvre est l'avenir
de notre jeunesse l'avenir de nos
étudiants leur prise en considération
par les pouvoirs publics dans un pays où
il ya plus en plus de jeunes qui font
des études supérieures
il en va de l'avenir de notre nation
donc il faudra vraiment posé le problème
j'espère que tous les candidats seront
le 16e jean yves le conte qu'est-ce
qu'il faut proposer à nos jeunes
notamment vu l'élection présidentielle
et même pour d'abord résoudre leurs
problèmes concrets du quotidien on sait
qu emmanuel macron va mettre en place un
revenu d'engagement des jeunes c'est une
bonne solution selon vous c'est il faut
leur proposer un revenu de sécurité là
je pense déjà que les dispositifs
sociaux qui commence à 25 ans il faut
qu'ils commencent à 18 ans
on sait qu'il ya une période où beaucoup
de jeunes sont en difficulté ils n'ont
pas besoin de la crise sanitaire
pourrait être en difficulté et donc ça
la garantie jeunes le droit aux
dispositifs sociaux qui commence à 25
ans à 18 ans ça doit être un vrai combat
mais au-delà de ça comme vous comme vous
l'indiquez il ya de plus en plus de
jeunes qui sont candidats pour des
études supérieures un dispositif de
l'enseignement supérieur et non
dimensionné pour pour la demande
aujourd'hui et aidons des étudiants qui
même au delà la crise sanitaire vive
finalement assez mal avec une
administration des universités qui ne
suis pas leurs dossiers d'aidé et des
jeunes qui depuis deux ans a
l'impression d'être à l'abandon et je
crois que lorsqu'il voit la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur parle et comme
elle a parlé maintenant ils ont
l'impression d'une déconnexion absolue
ils ont été en détresse totale et et je
dirais pas simplement sur le plan
matériel sur le plan de leurs
perspectives
sachant en plus voilà la crise kovy de
l'incapacité d'avoir des ddd échangent
entre eux pour se tenir les coudes dans
des dents dans des logements parfois
très très très très réduits ou qui
n'avaient pas les moyens de payer enfin
voila c'est tout ça ça interroge sur
l'ensemble de notre enseignement
supérieur
zoug as pour nos jeunes précaires qui
vivent en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
est ce que ce revenu d'engagement des
jeunes emmanuel macron ça peut être une
solution mais j'ai compris que les
étudiants n'étaient pas dans le
dispositif est ce qu'on attendait c'est
que justement il ya une réforme des
bourses je crois que le jeu je suis
entièrement d'accord avec ce qu'on dit
mais mes collègues je crois que
aujourd'hui il faut que l'état et la
france envoie un message très fort aux
jeunes en disant que leur cursus
universitaire c'est une chance pour la
france et il faut que l'état les aide
parce qu'ils représentent notre avenir
en termes de connaissances en termes
aussi de faire face à la plus grande
transformation
économique que le monde occidental
inconnu depuis l'essor du charbon c'est
à dire tout changement climatique on va
être confronté à un changement radical
de notre société on peut pas le faire
sans connaissance et d'universités c'est
d'abord ça alors en tout cas il y avait
des jeunes qui regardent et cette séance
de questions d'actualité au gouvernement
cet après midi sur public sénat et sur
la plateforme twitter une science
commenté par jean macé avec toute sa
communauté jean est ce que justement
cette question de la précarité étudiante
et bien elle a interpellé la communauté
cet après midi absolument c'est une
question qui est interpellé toute la
communauté et toutes les personnes qui
ont regardé on a bien vu vous tous qu'on
est entré dans la dernière année du
quinquennat et donc dans l'année du
bilan on a vu jean castex très combatif
sur ces sujets là et on a vu des
sénateurs et des sénatrices assez peu
convaincue par les arguments avancés par
jean castex notamment dès lors qu'il
ressort tout les toutes les tous les
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place
uniquement dans le cadre du code vide et
qui sont donc pas des choses de très
long terme on a aussi vu les le sujet
abordé par jacques le nay sur la
question des talibans en afghanistan une
question très intéressante et très bien
posée à jean yves le drian que fait la
france où en est la france et on a vu un
jean yves le drian le chef de la
diplomatie qui marche sur des oeufs très
terre à terre qui explique qu'il ya très
peu de relations avec le gouvernement
taliban et des relations qui sont voilà
très distantes et puis le dernier sujet
qui a beaucoup intéressé les internautes
c'est la question de la réforme des
retraites qui a été abordé les pieds
dans le plat si je puis le dire par rené
paul savary qui a dénoncé le renoncement
du gouvernement sur la réforme des
retraites et qui a prévu et qui a prédit
assez peu d'avenir alors à laurent
pietrasinski qui lui a eu du mal à
expliquer que cette réforme des
retraites bien que nécessaire murray pas
lieu a priori tant que la situation
sanitaire en gros il a paraphrasé ce
qu'avait déjà dit jean castex hier bref
les sénateurs on a senti que les
sénateurs de droite étaient sur leur
faim et qu'ils attendent vraiment un
retour de la réforme des retraites merci
beaucoup genre oubliez pas qu est ce que
vous êtes sur votre faim avec cette
réforme des retraites est ce que comme l
a dit rené paul savary le gouvernement a
abdiqué il a peut-être abdiqué fait le
gouvernement c'est une sont des
apprentis danseurs de tango un pas en
arrière trois pas en avant en fonction
des ballons des séquences mais je pense
très franchement qu'on ne lance pas une
réforme des retraites six mois avant une
échéance majeure c'est ça doit être une
des questions centrales qui sera
présenté aux français et je pense qu'il
faudra avoir un certain courage à ce
niveau là et là là ça serait vraiment
plus que la politique de gribouille
excusez moi mais je veux revenir un tout
petit instant sur la problématique des
jeunes pour montrer à quel point
peut-être que le gouvernement doit
effectivement prendre des mesures mais
c'est toute la société qui va évoluer je
vais vous prendre un exemple nous trois
nous sommes employeur nous avons des
collaborateurs j'ai voulu prendre un
jeune en alternance eh bien nous n'en
avons pas le droit
par le droit de c'est dans le règlement
aussi bien de l'assemblée nationale du
sénat alors l'assemblée est en train de
réfléchir
r changer le système mais c'est un bon
exemple pour montrer que c'est toute la
société qui ne fait pas forcément les
efforts nécessaires pour intégrer tous
ces jeunes qu'ils soient universitaires
à l'université où qu'ils soient dans des
missions locales ou autre on a beaucoup
à faire on a beaucoup à faire mais moi
je serais le premier heureux de pouvoir
engager un jeune en alternance c'est ce
que j'avais souhaité faire je n'ai pas
pu faire pendant septembre on va évoquer
un autre sujet d'urgence il s'agit de la
situation sanitaire en outre-mer
situation très inquiétante avec des taux
d'incidence record ce matin le sénat a
voté en faveur de la prorogation de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire en outre-mer
et il en a été question cet après midi
dans les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement quentin avec notamment et
bien des échanges sur la vaccination en
outre-mer oui tout à fait les taux de
vaccination qui sont bien inférieures en
outre mer qu'en métropole on est trop
pâle on est à la 73 % de primo à
vacciner maintenant parlons dans toute
la france on est à 73% et on a des taux
qui oscille entre 30 35% à en guadeloupe
en martinique
et justement on a eu une question de
victorin lurel cette vaccination le
sénateur de guadeloupe qui lui se dit
favorable à l'obligation vaccinale on va
voir cet échange avec olivier ferrand
louise de la santé d'abord on écoute de
sénateur de guadeloupe
sur ses bancs notre position est claire
et connue de tous c'est l'obligation
vaccinale
progressive universelle et gratuite
pour votre part que comptez vous faire
pour l'avenir comptez-vous mais tenir
encore longtemps ce pass sanitaire
profondément inégalitaire et intrusif
quand comptez vous en faire tes pour
l'obligation vaccinale seule mesure de
nature à concilier les libertés
individuelles et la protection de tous
et ont colligé véran lui a répondu en
admettant que eh bien on pouvait
débattre mais que ce débat sur
l'obligation vaccinale il était
confronté très réalité très rapidement à
la réalité de la vaccination dans ces
territoires écoutez mise la santé on
peut débattre de cela met alors à
laquelle je vous parle il ya 75 % où 70%
de la population de guyane qui n'est pas
vaccinée j'attends donc avec impatience
sa proposition de loi que vous déposerez
pour savoir quelles sont les sanctions
qui s'appliqueront dès lors que cette
loi sera applicable à 70% de la
population de guyane qui n'est pas
vacciné encourager nous à vacciner les
populations de métropole et d'outre-mer
la cinquième la quatrième vague monsieur
le sénateur n'est pas le fait d'une
carence hospitalière ou services publics
elle est le fait d'un virus invisible
contagieux qui fait des ravages qui
circule partout et dans tous les pays où
ils circulent en revanche on sait qu'il
ya une chose qui lui permet qui permet
d'éviter qu'ils circulent et qui fasse
des ravages la vaccination olivier
ferrand qui a semblé confondre la guyane
et la guadeloupe victorin lurel qui est
bien un sénateur de guadeloupe et donc
vous le disiez alex ce matin le sénat a
adopté un l'état d'urgence c'est la
progression des cas d'urgence sanitaire
dans les territoires d'outre-mer sont
concernés la guadeloupe la martinique
saint barthélemy saint martin ainsi que
la guyane la réunion et la polynésie
française et qui peuvent voir et bien
des confinement des couvre feux comme
cela jusqu'au au moins au 15 novembre
merci beaucoup quand on poursuit ses
réactions sur l'urgence sanitaire en
outre-mer puisque steve jourdain et en
salle des conférences avec le sénateur
de polynésie le sénateur du groupe r des
pays la république en marche teva
rofritsch
oui teva rofritsch bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous à la fin du mois d'août
vous avez fait part de votre extrême
inquiétude sur la situation sanitaire en
polynésie on en est où aujourd'hui nous
sommes toujours inquiet parce que nous
ne sommes malheureusement pas sorti de
cette situation dramatique que nous
vivons depuis quelques semaines vous
savez nous avons un temps atteint des
taux d'incidence au corps près de 4000
aux îles sous-le-vent plus de 3500 aux
îles du vent
c'est la première fois depuis très
longtemps que la polynésie est
confrontée à une épidémie aussi
meurtrière puisqu'on a passé la barre
des 500 morts et je le disais ce matin
pour qu'on relativise pascal échelle la
nation peut-être 500 morts et il ya eu
des drames aussi en métropole bien sûr
lorsque la des week-ends les plumes à
trier 55 morts en deux jours c'est le
double d accidents de la route ont eu
une année en polynésie donc vous
imaginez l'impact psychologique
globalement sur la population et puis
les g pour les familles le sénat a
adopté vous l'avez dit on ce matin la
prorogation de l'état d'urgence en outre
mer elle était nécessaire cette
prolongation 6 absolument et urgente
pour la polynésie parce que nous avons
nous avons atteint la limite du
précédent texte il aurait fallu lever
les mesures aujourd'hui pour mise en
place pour couper les chaînes de
contamination ou au 11 septembre c'est
la section leçon à qui vit avec lui
comment finalement pas la population à
bas aujourd'hui elles sont accueillies
comment dire avec détermination dans la
mesure où tout le monde a compris
localement
pour ne pas dire la quasi totalité de la
population
bien entendu mettre en oeuvre ces
recommandations et ces mesures parce
qu'il faut à tout prix stopper la
contamination c'est vrai qu'en polynésie
comme dans beaucoup d'îles on a
l'habitude des accolades en al'habitude
effectivement d'avoir une un lien
physique différent des pays en europe
mais en même temps tout le monde a dû
bien se résoudre dans la mesure où ce
virus et le delta en particulier
particulièrement virulent et voilà il
n'y a pas d'autre solution que de
réduire un maximum les contacts aux
contacts essentiels néanmoins l'activité
économique se poursuit puisque les
entreprises peuvent continuer de
fonctionner mais comment dire les
contacts entre personnes les contacts
familiaux
les rassemblements sont aujourd'hui
strictement limité parce qu'il le faut
bien vous faites partie de la majorité
présidentielle vous êtes sénateur des
pays on a appris aujourd'hui la
convocation d'agnès busin ce vendredi à
la cour de justice de la république en
vue d'une possible mise en examen quelle
est votre réaction là dessus écoutez je
ne veux pas me prononcer parce que je
suis aussi magistrale à cause de justice
de la république donc il m'appartient
pas pour le moment de commenter ceci jeu
j'attends la suite de la procédure en
cours sur la sorgue peut être un mot sur
la forme sur la cour de justice de la
république la cour de justice de la
république et sa composition à
parité entre l'assemblée nationale le
sénat m'ont bien qu'il y ait un contrôle
qui est exercée par le pouvoir
législatif et par le parlement sur
l'action du gouvernement donc ça ne me
semble pas surprenant que des commandes
y a que des sujets lui soit soit soumis
à
sa sagacité ensuite il appartient à la
justice de suivre son cours et nous
verrons bien le moment venu merci
merci beaucoup steve situation d'extrême
urgence sanitaire en outre-mer pierre
aux audiences la cause de cette
situation en outre-mer est ce qu'elle
est social le manque de moyens de
l'hôpital public aussi peut-être une
forme de précarité ou est ce qu'il ya
aussi la vaccination c'est à dire une
population qui n'est pas allé sur
vacciner parce que ce que j'observe
c'est que là la carte du faible taux de
vaccination c'est celle des territoires
pauvres que ça soit en métropole ou dans
dans les outre-mer il ya des territoires
oubliés de la république dont lesquelles
malheureusement l'accès au droit
et au service public est de plus en plus
difficile et les gens n'ont plus
confiance parce que l'état pour eux ça
ne représente plus quelque chose de
positif il ya une forme de retrait par
rapport par rapport à la nation moi
demain matin je vous invite à
m'accompagner j'irai à à bagneux avec la
croix rouge au pied des tours et un
barnum les bénévoles monte dans les
tours et vont chercher les allées les
gens les uns après les autres et là il
ya une relation de confiance parce
qu'elle se fait avec des gens qui se
connaissent ce que nous on propose c'est
la solidarité et la seule réponse de
gouvernement c'est la sanction
il faut absolument sanctionné pour
obliger c'est pas comme ça qu'on y
arrivera je pense qu'il faut faire
autrement il faut aller chercher les
gens avec beaucoup de pédagogie et
d'humilité parce qu'on est responsable
dans ce qui leur arrive olivier paccaud
quel est votre solution pour augmenter
la vaccination est ce que c'est la
solidarité ou est ce que c'est la
responsabilité
les deux je pense que alors je serai un
tout petit peu moins sévère que pierre
concernant justement le lien entre
problématiques sociales et vaccination
parce que là il ya un vrai déficit
outre-mer il était peut-être pas préparé
en fait et administrativement et
psychologiquement à vivre
l'explosion du variant delta néanmoins
je reprend les termes de pierre
ouzoulias s'il faut beaucoup de
pédagogie aujourd'hui pour les
convaincre de l'utilité
de la nécessité de vaccination et moi je
pense que l'état aujourd'hui fait ce
qu'il faut nous avons tous voté
d'ailleurs à l'unanimité le texte de
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire ce matin de la pédagogie
également de la clarté jean yves le
conte et sénateurs socialistes justement
sur la question de la vaccination sont
favorables à une obligation vaccinale
alors pas forcément que pour les
territoires ultramarins pour tous les
français est ce que ça pourrait être une
solution pour améliorer cette stratégie
de vaccination
quand nous en parlons nous parlons d'une
vaccination universelle
en disant finalement perdre tracer une
perspective parce que s'il n'y a pas
cette obligation vaccinale si nous ne
disons pas à tout le monde vacciner vous
et ça doit être accessible à tous alors
on aura encore des territoires et des
personnes qui ne seront pas vaccinés et
à partir de là le club le virus pourra
continuer à courir donc c'est une
question de responsabilité et de
conviction et et c'est assez finalement
significatif que lorsque nous parlons de
vaccination au vaccination universelle
en essayant de convaincre le ministre
répond c'est pas universelle et c'est
pas obligatoire puisque a pas de
sanction passé c'est un état d'esprit
particulier quand même nous nous voulons
convaincre nous voulons convaincre et
nous savons en particulier dans l'autre
mais au delà de ce qu'indiquait pire aux
audiences il ya quand même aussi des
traumatismes et des manque de confiance
due à d'autres scandales sanitaires
précédent qui font que l'état voilà il
ya un déficit de confiance et qu'il faut
essayer de le gagner il y avait aussi un
déficit d'offre c'est à dire que on n'a
pas traité ces territoires normalement
en france il y avait toute la palette
des vaccins reconnu par l'agencé
européenne du médicament c'est le cas
par cas dans tous les territoires
outre-mer donc à partir de dollars des
traumatismes liés à dents à d'autres
scandales sanitaires que l'état n'a pas
correctement géré plus cette hausse de
palette d'offres qui était qui était qui
était pas complète voilà vraiment le
sentiment d'être en deuxième jaune avec
un déficit de confiance donc il faut
effectivement
faire évoluer les choses mais à la fin
la vaccination obligatoire c'est la
seule manière de ne pas discriminer
entre les obligations warrants veut
faire les soignants aujourd'hui demain
peut-être les enseignants après après
les policiers fac qu'est ce que c'est
que ça c'est une obligation citoyenne et
donc l'obligation de restaurer la
confiance avant de retourner en salle
des conférences pierre aux usages de
vous libérer puisque vous allez dans
quelques instants auditionné la ministre
vidal et pour finir cette émission va
évoquer l'hommage national à jean paul
belmondo en hommage qui est rendu cet
après midi aux invalides en présence du
président de la république et en salle
des conférences steve jourdain vous êtes
avec un des sénateurs qui étaient
proches de là heures le sénateur
philippe tabarot sénateurs les
républicains ont des alpes-maritimes
oui philippe d'abord bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous allez participer à
cette cérémonie en hommage à jean paul
belmondo dans quelques instants c'est un
homme que vous avez connu c'est un homme
dont vous étiez proche j'imagine que ça
va être un moment assez spécial pour
vous oui c'est avec beaucoup d'émotion
je me rends à cette cérémonie à la fois
comme tous les français je suis très
affecté par cette nouvelle par rapport à
ce qu'il peut représenter de notre
patrimoine national mais j'ai eu
également la chance de le côtoyer depuis
une dizaine d'années sur la côte d'azur
où il était un fidèle et il venait
régulièrement nous nous rendre visite
donc majoré en mémoire tous les moments
assez exceptionnel qu'on a pu partager
alors parmi ces moments peut-être que
vous pouvez nous en rendre compte nous
en raconter en une anecdote peut-être
sur jean paul belmondo écoutez vous
savez quand vous avez l'occasion de
rencontrer quelqu'un qui était une idole
pour vous vous ne pouvez en général
qu'être déçu avec jean paul belmondo
il était encore mieux je dirais dans la
vie de tous les jours que l'image qu'on
en a aussi mais je n'ai jamais vu refusé
pendant des années un autographe une une
photo je n'ai jamais vu avoir un geste
d'humeur avec qui que ce soit d'une
gentillesse d'une politesse et puis
laver un courage exceptionnel malgré son
handicap et l'accident qui a été le sien
il se plaignait jamais et il avait
toujours le sourire toujours la banane
et puis quand on a fait de belles bouffe
entre guillemets et quelques apéros bien
arrosée aussi mais il aimait la vie et
c'était un vrai bonheur de l'entendre
raconter notamment avec charles gérard
des anecdotes assez exceptionnel sur sur
leur vie sur leur amitié et puis sur le
cinéma français vous êtes un homme
politique de quoi on parle avec jean
paul belmondo quand on est un homme
politique il avait pas les mêmes idées
que vous je crois non il avait des idées
politiques bien arrêter je n'en parlais
pas aujourd'hui j'avais l'occasion cgt
d'en discuter avec lui voilà c'est un
homme de qui avait des idées pour notre
pays qui qui pensaient que certaines
choses devaient être améliorées en tout
cas ils avaient sur ces sujets vraiment
des arguments très pertinents
et puis on avait une passion en commun
c'était le sport
et notamment la boxe on est tous les
deux passionnés de boxe on a vu de
nombreux combats de boxe sur la côte
d'azur ensemble vous êtes battu l'un
contre l'autre oh non on était à côté
ont commenté en donner nos favoris
pendant les différentes reprises et les
différents rounds et et puis on parler
football aussi parce que c'était une
encyclopédie de la boxe et du football
lui qui a été un des fondateurs du paris
saint-germain en trois mots qu'est ce
que vous attendez de cette cérémonie aux
invalides aujourd'hui écoutés j'espère
que ça va être quelque chose de
solennel bien sûr parce que c'est un
événement est le lieu s'y prête mais
également quelque chose de simple parce
que jean paul belmondo était quelqu'un
d'excessivement simple qui n'aimait pas
un protocole particulier qui était
toujours décontracté toujours en dehors
un petit peu de de certains schémas donc
j'espère que ce sera une cérémonie qui
lui ressemblera en tout cas voilà je
pense que c'est une très belle chose que
le pays tout entier puissent lui rendre
hommage simplicité merci beaucoup
philippe tabarot répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup steve et c'est déjà la
fin de cette émission merci beaucoup
olivier paccaud et jean yves le coz
d'avoir participé et bien c'est cette
première émission des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement de la
rentrée parlementaire je vous souhaite
une très bonne soirée sur public sénat
[Musique]